So Leute auf gehts, oh oh Teams, Teams hat mein Sound wiederverstellt, MonkaS, so ein
Kacktool, schreck mich da jeden Tag drüber auf ähm, duu, na geht da eigentlich, gar
nicht so wild, gar nicht so wild, aber ich hör das sofort, dass Teams da irgendwie
dran herumgesaut hat. Exellent, exellent. So, Poggers! Auf gehts, de, de, de, de, de, de,
halt riecht Hacker Man wieder. Massive Hacker Mans. Oh ich glaub ich sollte mal bevor ich
hier rum renne gleich im Zimmer und die Switcher auspacke sollte ich vielleicht erstmal mein
Headset ein bisschen entknoten, ja.
Ja, passt.
So, erstmal warten bis der Stream on ist.
Oh Mist, ich hab ne, ich seh's grad,
ich hab hier so ne Falte im Teppich.
Da roll ich jetzt jedes Mal mit dem Stuhl drüber.
Das sackt.
Das müsst ich mal eben wieder gerade machen.
Aber hier ist grad eh so viel Umgeräume
und sonst was. Ihr werdet auch gleich
ein bisschen Kabelsalat sehen.
Zumindest am Rand sieht man glaub ich ein bisschen Kabelsalat.
Moin, müssen wir mal gucken,
ob ich die Kamera richtig eingestellt hab,
Leute, ob man...
ob man den Kabelsalat...
Ja, ein bisschen, ein bisschen.
Bisschen Kabelsalat sieht man hier unten an der Seite.
Die, die, die, die, die.
Finger leak.
Monkeyes.
Finger.
Da is er.
Original.
Maxsauce Finger.
Hat man im Stream schon öfters gesehen.
Boomer Finger hier.
Bo, Bo, Boomer Finger.
Zwei Boomer Finger.
Huge Subscriptions hier wieder.
Die Azubi Chitribo, die hab ich doch schon 50 Mal im Stream erzählt.
Boomer Finger hier.
Boomer Finger.
Die hab ich doch schon 50 Mal im Stream erzählt.
Einmal, wenn du das noch nicht kennst,
dann musst du aufs Video warten.
Vielleicht erzähl ich doch im Laufe des Abends auch nochmal, wenn es Mitternacht ist.
Cloud Switch.
Ja, Poggers.
Ja, mal ein bisschen ausprobieren.
So sieht's aus.
Müssen wir die Emotes ein bisschen mehr verwenden?
Wir haben jetzt so viele nice Emotes,
die...
ich mir nicht Anzeigen lassen kann,
weil ich eingeloggt bin.
Pazip.
Moin. Nice Twitch Prime Subscription.
Huge.
IQ Upgrade.
Was ist denn ein Cloud Switch?
Ein Cloud Switch ist was,
wo Mikrotik
einfach einen geilen Namen draufschreiben will.
10G Incoming.
Na, ich hab ja schon 10G.
10G.
Ok, Leute.
Wir raten jetzt mal.
Was ist das, was ich hier in...
was ich...
ins Bild halte?
Wer rät's? Wir machen jetzt mal...
Massive Quiz.
Es steht sogar drauf,
lulwe.
Man hat sogar erkannt, was es ist.
Hentai Tentacle. Nein, das ist falsch.
Und Coq ist es auch nicht.
Das ist das Raspberry Pi 4 case.
Richtig.
Ähm, machen wir mal was anderes.
Jetzt bin ich mal...
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob ihr das erratet.
Moment, Moment.
Erst mal was Schwieriges.
Erst mal die schwierige Variante.
Was ist das?
Es ist nicht Jep Coq.
So viel kann ich schon mal verraten.
Messer.
Meint ihr immer noch, dass es ein Messer ist?
Richtig. Korrekt.
Das ist der einzig wahre
Abisoliert Champ.
Ihr habt es richtig erkannt.
Der ist natürlich auch am Start.
Den brauchen wir heute Abend allerdings nicht,
weil heute Abend gibt es nichts zum Abisolieren.
Aber der muss immer mit dabei sein.
Der Abisoliert Champ.
Beste.
Finger League.
Ja, das haben wir schon öfters im Stream gehabt.
Die ist nice.
Übrigens, die Unterlage wackelt ein bisschen.
Weil das
sich irgendwie verzogen hat.
Oh, staubig. Guck mal hier was.
Monka Staub.
Das hat sich ein bisschen
verzogen und jetzt musste ich es vorher
festschrauben und ich habe glaube ich nicht so bis auf den letzten
Millimeter festgeschraubt.
Spiegelt sich alles im Abisoliert Champ.
Okay, okay.
Haben wir noch irgendwas zum raten?
Okay, das ist easy.
Das erkennt ihr sofort.
Also jeder, der es schon mal gesehen hat,
erkennt es an den Farben.
Was ist das?
Seitenschneider.
Seitenschneider, genau.
Richtig, Seitenschneider.
Okay, genug Quizchamp würde ich sagen.
Oder doch, doch, doch, warte mal, warte mal.
Ein Quizchamp
machen wir noch, weil da wisst ihr nicht was es ist.
Fakt, das steht drauf,
was es ist. Das ist schlecht.
Das kann ich nicht zeigen.
Moment, ich will jetzt noch
ein Quizchamp machen.
Ein Quizchamp, was, was, was, was, was, was
machen wir da jetzt?
Okay, da, da kommt ihr nicht drauf.
Da kommt ihr nicht drauf, außer die im Stream dabei.
Was ist das?
Oh guck mal, wenn ich mit dem Fuß auf die Erde
dingse, dann wackelt die Kamera. Exzellent.
Das ist kein USB Stick.
Nein, auch kein Powerlogger.
Ah,
Powermeter.
Nee.
5G, nee.
Das ist
einfach ein USB Relay.
Du kannst damit USB Geräte, Remote
an und ausschalten hier. Du kannst entweder den Knopf
drücken, dann wird das USB Gerät an und
ausgeschaltet oder du kannst es ins W-Lan
hängen, da ist nämlich ein ESP32
glaube ich drauf. Und du kannst
übers W-Lan USB Geräte ein und ausschalten.
Das kann man nicht erraten,
wenn man nicht zufällig mal im Stream dabei
gewesen ist. Das geht nicht.
So,
ich zeige euch jetzt mal kurz, bevor wir richtig
loslegen, mal die Switche, die ich gekauft habe.
Also, ich habe einmal den hier am Start.
Und,
ach so, die Musik müssen wir gerade mal wechseln.
Hier.
Ah, yes.
Das klingt doch gleich schon
deutlich fröhlicher.
Äh, kannst du mal LinkedIn,
Excel und C-Sharp-Zertifizierung
machen?
Haben die sowas?
Ich soll jetzt auf der Arbeit massig
Azure-Schulungen machen.
Mein Chef hat mir heute ein PDF geschickt
mit, jetzt ohne Scheiß,
ich habe nicht gezählt, aber ich würde sagen 300
Azure-Schulungen. Er hat gemeint, ja such mal aus.
Dann habe ich gesagt, äh, ich weiß überhaupt nicht,
um was es da geht, die meisten Wörter sagen mir
noch nichts.
Ich so, was soll ich mir da auszuholen?
Ja, such dir mal irgendwas aus, ist egal.
Gut, habe ich mir irgendwas ausgesucht.
LinkedIn-Zertifikate, ernsthaft?
Ah, nee.
Wenn das nicht ein bisschen klein?
Nennst du es der Switch oder die Switch?
Äh, der Switch.
Oder den Switch.
Die passt irgendwie in dem Fall nicht,
oder? Also die Konsole,
die Konsole ist die Switch.
Und der Netzwerk-Switch
ist der Switch.
Also komplett Gleichberechtigung gibt die Switch
und der Switch.
Die Nintendo-Switch
und der Netzwerk-Switch, genau.
So sieht es aus. So.
Und...
Switch innen, das könnte man auch machen, ja.
Manchmal irritiert mich das ja ein bisschen.
Wie ihr wisst, ich bin Fan,
dass jeder machen kann, was er will.
Aber manche Twitter-Profile
irritieren mich doch,
wenn ich da reingucke.
Es ist ja so im Trend,
dass man in sein Twitter-Profil oben reinschreibt,
wie man angesprochen werden will.
Das ist ja in der heutigen Zeit auch gut,
weil es ist ja nicht mehr so
auf den ersten Blick oftmals erkennbar.
Und da stehen dann manchmal
so viele Twitter-Profile,
die man als erkennbar. So.
Und da stehen dann manchmal so Sachen drin, wie
dass jemand
innen, keine Ahnung,
ein Wolf ist oder sowas.
Wo ich mir dann so denke, äh, what?
Da blick ich dann nicht mehr durch, Alter.
Dann hört es dann auf bei mir.
Oder ein Lama oder so, habe ich sogar
schon mal gesehen.
Naja, aber wie gesagt, jeder wie er will.
Wo Plan?
7 Monate Massive IQ Explosion.
Nein, kein Dark Mode.
Ich mache auch keinen Dark Mode an,
weil ich habe hier die übelste fette Beleuchtung am Start.
Wenn ich Dark Mode anmache, gucke ich auf
den Monitor und
erst mal Dark Mode, dann gucke ich wieder in das
Elgato Ringlight so instant blind.
So.
Also, einmal haben wir das Ding am Start.
Das ist ein
4-Port-10G-Switch
mit einem
1G PoE-Port.
Und das da
ist ein 8-Port-
1G-Switch und
Alter, die Bilder sind ja mal wieder
Massive, Massive Suck, Alter.
Nein, nein, ich will nicht
Map, ich will Bilder, Bilder, nicht Images.
Und 2 10G-Ports.
Warum kein Cisco-Router?
Gibst du mir Geld, dann kaufe ich mir Cisco-Router.
Kann man alles machen.
Kann man aber auch sein lassen.
Außerdem, außerdem, Cisco, Cisco,
wenn Cisco ist, dann ist es definitiv ein Router.
Bist du auf Windows oder Linux?
Wenn das Windows ist,
verwirrt mich die schnelle
Linux-Performance. Das ist der Host
des Windows, der Host des Windows, siehst du auch hier
an den Windows-Desktops.
Das ist Windows.
Und ich habe einfach auf dem zweiten Desktop
eine VM. Guck hier.
Linux-VM auf dem zweiten Desktop.
Mit, ganz wichtig,
wer seine VM nicht mit FPS-Anzeige
betreibt,
verliert FPS.
Das Allerwichtigste
ist, dass man in der VM weiß,
wie schnell man die Maus gerade bewegt in FPS.
Ansonsten ist das einfach
Low-Brain.
So, das habe ich am Start.
Dann habe ich noch, falls wir
brauchen,
habe ich auch noch einen
Ollen,
3, Raspberry Pi 3
am Start. Also hier,
da.
Exquisite. Aber ich glaube, den brauchen wir
nicht. Ich glaube, der Vierer, der da hinten,
der Ecklicht, der reicht jetzt erstmal.
Und ich habe es nicht hingekriegt,
diesen komischen Treiber für die
Netzwerkkarte zu installieren. Also ich zeige
mal kurz was.
Also hier haben wir einen Raspberry Pi 4.
Mit,
hier guck mal,
richtig Boomer-Hemd.
Muss ja auch passen.
Programm hier. Also ich habe hier zum Test
ein paar Sachen am Start. Ich zeige euch das mal.
Dazu muss ich allerdings aufstehen,
weil ich habe das
Setup ein bisschen höher gebaut.
Und wenn ich jetzt nicht aufstehe,
dann komme ich dann richtig dran.
Ich muss noch meinen Stuhl wegschieben.
Das heißt, ich muss mich immer mal zwischendrin umdrehen für den Chat.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt mal kurz was nicht
sehe, dann
sehe ich es halt kurz nicht. Also ich zeige
euch mal kurz, was wir am Start haben. Und zwar wir haben einmal
...
Leute, ich brauche unbedingt hier neben
so eine Vorschau.
Ich brauche unbedingt so eine Vorschau für den Stream.
Ich überlege gerade.
Oh Leute, ich habe
Massive-Brain-Idee. Ich hole jetzt
mein Tablet. Ich hole mein Tablet und mache
die Stream-Vorschau drauf an. Wartet mal,
ich bin gleich wieder da.
Brains, Alter. Massive.
So, ich bin gleich wieder da. Ich muss jetzt
noch mal auf dem Tablet das Ganze aufmachen.
Tablet.
Ich brauche nämlich den Invite-Link. By the way, den
Invite-Link müsst ihr nicht ausprobieren. Der geht externe.
Chrome aufmachen.
Und jetzt,
wie ist die Adresse im Moment?
View FT. Ach, du
große Scheiße. Wir denken sich so
einen Kack aus.
Hallo Tablet, please funktionieren.
Lass mir den ganzen
Müll zumachen, der da noch läuft.
Hätte ich schon vorher machen sollen, aber
ich brauche eine Vorschau.
Static.
OBS
Ninja.
Und jetzt
brauchen wir was?
FT
T
F
C
Okay, und jetzt
sollte der Mist auf dem Tablet aufgehen, hoffe ich,
wenn ich es richtig gemacht habe.
Ja, Chat,
I'm in, ist klar, ist klar.
Okay, nice. Und jetzt muss ich mal gucken.
Muss ich das jetzt, muss ich das so hinstellen,
dass ich mich nicht leake, Leute.
Not, not leake,
nicht leake.
Not, not leaked.
Sodass ich mich nicht, nicht,
nicht leake.
So.
Sehe ich jetzt hier was?
Excellent, excellent.
Sehr gut.
Jetzt sehe ich nämlich so ungefähr, was ich mache.
So der
Spur nach. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt
hier was nehme und zeige
das in die Kamera, dann kann ich auf
den Vorschau gucken, ob die Kamera
das richtig fokussiert und macht.
Das ist schon mal ganz gut.
Leaked.
So.
Also. Hosen leaked. Oh ne, stimmt.
Hose, Hose ist geleaked. Shit.
Hose ist geleaked.
War hier gerade das Hosen leaked?
Da Hosen leaked? Ne.
MonkaS.
Haare leaked?
Also ich habe Haare leaked?
Wie soll ich denn Haare geleaked haben?
So. Kann ich das vielleicht
noch ein bisschen schräg machen, dass ich auch was sehe?
Oder kann ich es hochkant machen
oder so? Hat mal das
gesagt.
Ich probiere das mal hochkant aus.
Hochkant besser?
Sehe ich da jetzt mehr?
Okay, okay, ist besser, ist besser.
Also.
Tja, mit was fangen wir jetzt mal an, Leute?
Cockleak.
Das wäre es jetzt. Da wäre ich schon
ein bisschen bammt, Alter.
So.
Ja, dann fangen wir mal an.
Also ich zeige mal, was wir, was wir am Start
haben. Wisst ihr, was ich noch unbedingt
bräuchte? So einen,
so ein Wireless, so ein Wireless
Ding zum labern.
Also ich zeige euch, was wir am Start haben
zum testen. Also wir haben einmal, oh fuck, wo
habe ich denn jetzt hin? Nein.
Wo habe ich denn
hin?
Wo habe ich den Gigabit Ethernet Adapter hin? Den hat
ich doch eben in der Hand.
Wo ist er?
Leute, chat.
Wer hat ihn weg?
Wer hat ihn?
Ich habe den euch doch eben gezeigt.
Liegt der jetzt dahinter oder was?
Was zum Teufel habe ich den hingelegt?
Beim Tablet holen mitgenommen, vielleicht?
Keine Ahnung, der ist immer da.
Boomer.
Gehirn, Alter.
Tja, wo ist denn der? Wo habe ich denn denn hin?
Kann doch nicht so weit hin sein.
Vielleicht habe ich den echt, ich glaube,
ich gucke mal kurz rum, ich glaube,
ich habe den beim Tablet holen mitgenommen.
Okay, da ist er nicht. Wir müssen jetzt erstmal den Adapter finden.
Der kann doch nicht weit sein. Ich meine,
hier sind die Switche. Hier ist das
alles klar, hier ist der Raspberry Pi.
Der Adapter, den habe ich eben in die Kamera gehalten.
Das heißt, ich kann den im Prinzip,
wenn ich mich rumgedreht habe, der liegt auf
meinem Stuhl, Leute.
Bester, der Adapter-Cham.
Da liegt er. Übrigens, wer sich fragt,
was das ist,
das hier
ist ein 2,5
Gigabit.
Also, ich muss jetzt ja gar nicht auf den Monitor gucken, ich kann hier unten hin
gucken. Das ist ein 2,5 Gigabit
Netzwerkadapter
über USB.
Und
die Sache ist die,
das Ding ist eigentlich ziemlich
crap. Das habe ich mal gekauft auf Amazon
für glaube 35 Euro, als es im Angebot war.
Und
der wird saumäßig
heiß. Und unter Linux funktioniert der nicht
wirklich gut. Aber gut genug,
um zu testen, ob die Dinger auch 2,5
Gigabit können, weil die Sache ist
nämlich die. Es ist wahrscheinlich
ja, dass demnächst 2,5
und 5 Gigabit Sachen
standardmäßig auch onboard auf Mainboards und so was
sind, im Vergleich
zu 10G. Ich glaube, 10G
wird es wahrscheinlich im Heimbereich
erstmal nicht geben, wobei es echt easy
ist, 10G.
Ich zeige euch
mal was. Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich noch eine Netzwerkkarte
habe. Wartet mal.
Und zwar
man kann einfach auf Ebay gehen.
Man kann einfach auf Ebay gehen
und sich so eine gebrauchte Karte kaufen.
Ihr fehlt das. Ihr fehlt das Loadplech,
aber das ist ja nicht
so das Ding, wenn ihr normalerweise
ein Loadplech dran. Das ist
irgendeine Melanox-Karte.
Hier, da steht es, was es ist.
Oder auch nicht.
Aber es ist ziemlich sicher
eine Melanox-Karte, glaube ich zumindest.
Steht nicht drauf, was auch immer.
Costed by Ebay,
also wie gesagt, das ist eine 10G-Karte.
Was ist das?
Vierfach, PCI-Express.
Und
das kostet 40 Dollar
oder so.
Baut ihr einen eigenen Router?
Nee, wir packen gleich einen Router
und einen Switch aus.
Also
genau, genau.
Das ist
ein Connex 3,
glaube ich. Das ist der mit PCI-Express 4.
Also der Kram kostet
wirklich nicht viel.
Bringt dir das
was, wenn man eine 100 MBit-Leitung
hat, sich sowas zu kaufen?
Das kommt drauf an. Also
fürs Internet bringt dir das nichts, weil 100 MBit
hast du ja gesagt, ist Schluss.
Aber wenn du intern zum Beispiel
eine NAS hast, wo du schnell Sachen übertragen willst
oder irgendwelche anderen Rechner mit SSD,
die auch 10G haben, dann bringt das was.
Und
natürlich bringt es
einen,
zumindest rechenrig niedrigeren
Ping.
Was aber bei der ganzen Latenz kaum eine Rolle spielt.
Aber man hat natürlich
die paar Biles für einen Ping mit 10G
schneller übertragen als mit 1G.
Rechnerisch ist das nicht weg
zu diskutieren, Chat.
Ja, also es ist eigentlich kein
Problem. Die meisten Leute
checken es bloß nicht. Also man kann sich heutzutage
echt günstig
einen 10G Setup bauen. Und jetzt passt mal auf.
Also ihr könnt euch so eine Karte kaufen
für, also ihr kommt mir fast wie
Shopping-Kanal oder so. Ihr könnt euch so eine
10G Karte kaufen für 30 Dollar
auf Ebay. Und dann
kauft ihr euch entweder den Switch oder
den Router-Switch oder den
oder den Switch, ich zeige es
gleich. Und
dann habt ihr für
sag mal, ihr braucht zwei Karten und
einen Switch, dann habt
ihr für ungefähr 150
oder 200 Euro einen 10G
Setup. Also da kannst du dich
wirklich nicht drüber beschweren.
Shopping 24,
ne, wenn schon der
Shopchamp
Shoppingchamp
Kaufchamp, der Kaufchamp
Leute, der
Kaufchamp. Oh, ich darf nicht so fest
auftreten. Guck mal, wenn ich da vor, wenn ich da vorum
stampfe, Pepofet-Schritte
am Start, dann wackelt die Kamera.
Was kann man dagegen machen?
Kann man die Kamera in irgendeinen
Gedingse hängen oder so?
Kaufchamp.org
Abnehmen. Ja, der Boden
wackelt. Das ist nicht sonderlich stabil.
Ich könnte Pepo-Leichtgewicht
sein und
guck mal, selbst wenn ich
selbst wenn ich den Stuhl wackele, wackelt
das schon. Und wie gesagt, das wackelt
nicht. Das wackelt gar nicht mal so
sehr. Der Tisch, der ist ziemlich fest.
Das ist halt hier das ganze Konstrukt,
weil der Boden halt wirklich wackelt, wenn ich
hier, das ist nicht sonderlich stabil.
Gimbal-Haltung. Exzellent.
Also, dann zeige
ich euch mal, was wir noch am Start haben. Also wie gesagt,
wir haben einmal zum Testen das 2,5G.
Das ist relativ wichtig
zu gucken, ob das die Switch auf
die Reihe kriegen.
Mit 2,5G, weil
2,5G ist angesagt
zur Zeit.
Genau.
Dann haben wir diese 10G-Karte,
die brauchen wir jetzt eigentlich nicht.
So, dann haben wir noch ein paar andere Sachen,
die ich auch erst nochmal zeigen muss. Ich leg den
ganzen Krempel mal da hinten hin.
Dann haben wir, wie gehabt,
einen Raspberry Pi 4.
Da gibt es, glaube ich, nicht allzu viel zu sagen.
Das ist halt ein Model B, also das
aktuelle. Das ist nicht der mit dem USB-Bug,
das ist der neue, der ohne USB-Bug.
So, machen wir das mal ab.
Schmeiß ich mal hier weg.
Ich muss ein bisschen Platz machen,
dass ich jetzt gleich die Switcher auspacken kann.
Wo leg ich denn das jetzt mal hin?
Hier hinter. So, perfekt.
Umhängt, Champ. So,
dann haben wir
zwei, ich glaube, das ist ungefähr
einen Meter Glasfaserkabel.
Für 10G auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt.
Zweimal, zweimal einen Meter.
Muss man ein bisschen aufpassen,
die darf man nicht so sehr biegen.
Das mögen die nicht so, wenn man die zu sehr biegt.
Also, wir haben hier zweimal
einen Meter Glasfaserkabel.
So.
Und das schmeiß ich mal hier
in die Ecke. Das brauch ich jetzt hier nicht
auf dem Tisch.
Leg das mal hier hin und
den Raspberry Pi und das Zeug mach ich ja auch mal
auf dem Tisch runter
und leg das mal hier auf den Schreibtisch.
Dass ich das jetzt gleich
auspacken kann. So.
Dann,
aber hier noch was, achso,
ja genau. Dann haben wir hier noch was Nices.
Wir haben zwei Module.
Ich hab jetzt nur die Ubiquiti-Module.
Die kommen dann später in den Port rein
für 10G. Hier vorne kommen die Glasfaser rein.
Ich zeig das mal, weil ich geh mal davon aus,
dass das noch nicht alle gesehen haben.
Also, so sehen die Module aus.
Also sprich, das ist das Gegenstück
von eurem AJ45-Stecker.
Normalerweise
hast du hier AJ45-Stecker
und hier hast du halt SFP-Module.
Ich muss übrigens gleich noch ein paar Netzwerkkabel holen.
Fällt mir auf, ein paar normale Netzwerkkabel brauchen wir auf jeden Fall auch noch.
Und, äh,
da nimmt man hier das Glasfaserkabel und macht das dann
ich mach das immer ver...
What the...
Ah guck mal, da ist noch der Schutz vorne drauf.
So sieht das nämlich in Wirklichkeit vorne aus.
So, hier.
Excellent.
Reingucken.
Ist immer besonders gut,
zum Checken, ob's funktioniert.
Gerade bei Sachen mit viel Power drauf.
Immer schön reingucken in die Glasfaserkabel,
ob alles funktioniert. Nee, bloß nicht machen, Leute.
Ohne Spaß.
Da kann man blind von werden.
Da kann man wirklich blind von werden.
Also, bei den Dingern jetzt nicht.
Bei den jetzt, bei diesem 10G-Zeug jetzt nicht.
Aber wenn ihr irgendwelche Dark-Fiber-Kabel
oder sonst was habt,
und ihr guckt da rein, dann könnt ihr wirklich
blind von werden. Das ist nicht ohne.
Das ist nicht ohne. Das heißt, das Beste, was man dann
machen kann ist vielleicht, also,
entweder mit dem Finger leuchten lassen, oder
auf dem Platt Papier leuchten lassen, oder irgendwas.
Oder am besten gar nirgendwo hin leuchten lassen und den Check
am Port nehmen.
Testest du die Endauf-Verschmutzung nicht?
Ich hab gar nichts dafür, um das zu testen.
Genau. So, und so
funktioniert das ganz.
By the way,
das macht man übrigens so, ne? Ich hab das falsch gezeigt.
Ich glaub, das... Warte mal.
Wie macht man das nochmal richtig? So?
Genau.
Das kann man irgendwie...
Dass es nicht so leicht rausgeht, fragt
mich nicht. Ich check's gar nicht, genau.
Ich glaub, man hat das dann irgendwie so...
Hat man das?
Ja. Chat, wer ist jetzt der Netzwerk-Profi?
Wie macht man das richtig? Was macht man
mit diesen komischen Dingern hier außer dran ziehen?
Und chat gucken.
Wer ist Big Brain?
Der ist zum...
Der ist zum, äh, rausziehen.
Ja, das weiß ich.
Ist der nur zum... Ist der nur...
Ist der nur zum rausziehen?
Ernsthaft?
Ich hab gedacht, damit könnte man vielleicht das Kabel noch
sicher vorm rausgehen. Okay, keine Ahnung.
Zumindest, wenn man das Modul
rausziehen will, braucht man auf jeden Fall den Knopf,
also den Hebel hier hinten dran.
So. Und so funktioniert das Ganze
dann. Glasfaserkabel,
zweimal Module. Auf geht's.
So.
Probieren wir dann aus.
Und hier
haben wir noch was. Massive.
Aber kein
Paints-Champ. Und zwar,
das ist die günstigste Variante
Switche mit SFP-Plus-Ports
miteinander zu verbinden.
Das ist ein Direct-Attached-Kabel. Das ist im Prinzip
ein Kupferkabel. Ich mach mal kurz hier.
Ihr seht, das ist relativ neu. Das hab ich schon nie verwendet.
Hier sind noch diese... Diese Dinger
dran. Na, da.
Ich mach das gerade mal ab.
Das ist immer...
Findet ihr das auch nicht so...
Ich find das ultra nervig, ey.
Diese...
Es ist gefuddelt mit diesen Dingern immer.
Wisst ihr was? Wisst ihr was? Wo
ist der... Wo ist der
Seidenschneider-Champ hin? Hier.
Wir machen uns jetzt gar nicht die Arbeit,
wenn man jetzt einfach hier...
Bloop.
Get schreckt. Warum sollte man das
aufdingen so, ne? Zack.
Sehr schön.
Dankeschön für den Sub. Ich kann grad nicht gucken.
Ich hab das Kabel in der Hand.
Ähm...
Sexyrexy185, danke schön für den Sub.
So.
Und das ist ein Direct-Attached-Kabel. 7 Meter.
Das ist das Längste, was geht.
Hab ich absichtlich genommen, weil ich wollte mal
ausprobieren, ob das funst.
7 Meter ist fragwürdig schon, ja.
So. Ähm...
Leg dich auf und schreib dich.
Und jetzt, Leute, ich wetz noch mal schnell raus
und hol noch ne Packung Netzwerkkabel.
Brauchen wir nämlich zum ausprobieren.
Auf geht's.
Jetzt guckt mal, was ich hier hab.
Nur für euch.
Extra, extra
für euch hab ich das aufgehoben.
RGB-Netzwerkkabel.
So.
Ich hab das aufgehoben.
Аh!
So ist es.
Ihr seht, die sind auch noch neu.
Warum das Kabel
fragwürdig ist, weil ich mal irgendwo
gelesen hab, dass du ab fünf Meter für
Direct-Attached-Kabel irgendwelche
Active Verstärker oder sowas
brauchst.
RGB-Netzwerkkabel,
und zwar, das sind, wie lang ist und das?
Das ist kein Meter. Das ist 25 whene
Zentimeter oder sowas, Mini-Netzwerk-Kabel, die werden wir wahrscheinlich auch gleich noch brauchen, denke ich mal.
So, aber ich würde sagen, jetzt gucken wir uns mal den Switch an. Switch-Champ.
Ich muss das jetzt alles mal auf einen Platz auf meinem Schreibtisch legen, weil sonst finisht das garantiert nicht mehr gleich.
So, Raspberry Pi Netzteil, muss auch weg.
Ach ja, und dann habe ich hinten noch im Serverraum, hier auf der anderen Seite, habe ich noch ein Modul.
Und zwar ein, das kann ich aber erst später holen, und zwar ein, wo habe ich?
Sekunde.
Und zwar so eins.
Allerdings, SF4 Plus auf RJ45. Das probieren wir auch aus, wie das mit den Switchen funktioniert.
Okay, Arm Revealed. Ich habe die ganze Zeit von Dingern Revealed. Okay, Leute, Chat, jetzt könnt ihr euch mal aussuchen.
Mit was voll, wir machen mal eine Abstimmung. Mit was wollen wir anfangen?
Wollen wir mit dem Router-Switch anfangen? Das ist der da oder mit dem Switch?
Also, wir machen mal, ich mache mal eine Abstimmung, mal gucken, wie das funktioniert, wie das geht.
Slash, Poll.
Also, mit was anfangen?
Viermal 10G Router-Switch.
Zwei mal 10G, acht mal 1G, Reiner-Switch.
Okay, gucken wir mal. Jetzt mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Jetzt müsste die Abstimmung, eigentlich müsste der Abstimmungs-Champ jetzt aktiv sein.
Jetzt aktiv sein.
Was ist bei 50-50? Dann beten wir den großen Pok-Champ an und gucken, was rauskommt.
Was rauskommt. Dann fragen wir Pierre Aguilé.
Wie lange habe ich die Umfrage eingestellt?
Wie lange geht das? Zwei Minuten, na gut, dann warten wir halt zwei Minuten.
Warum nicht? Kann ich mich noch mal kurz hinsetzen? Kann ich mich noch mal kurz hinsetzen, bevor ich jetzt die ganze Zeit hier vor diesem Presentator-Tisch rumstehen muss?
Okay, also Leute, ich würde sagen, der Viermal 10G Router-Switch ist etwas beliebter.
Was macht ein Switch? Naja, wenn du Snoop frage, ist Snoop Antwort, du verbindest Geräte miteinander.
Warum hast du meine Kontakte? Gibt es den Account noch? Ich dachte, die haben Herr Aguilé schon längst gelöscht.
Also, ich würde sagen, der Kleine hat gewonnen. Wir warten jetzt der Vollständigkeit halber noch.
By the way, ist da Sirius Max am Start?
Wir hatten doch mal irgendwo ein Tool. Hattest du nicht mal ein Tool gebastelt, wo alle Fragen mitgelockt werden, die an mich gehen?
Gibt es das noch? Weil ich kann heute nicht den Chat gucken. Das heißt, ich werde definitiv Zeug übersehen.
Was ist mit dem Salami-Emote passiert? Gibt es das nicht mehr? Es gibt kein Salami mehr? Warum das denn?
Das ist weg? Das Emote ist weg? Die haben das gelöscht?
Warum das denn? Warum... Was... Alter... Zerstört so ein Emote jetzt irgendwelche Leute oder was?
Man kann auch wirklich dafür sorgen, dass keiner mehr Spaß an irgendwas hat.
Ja, ich weiß. Das Emote ist entfernt. Sackt, Alter. Aber BetterTwitchTV hat das bestimmt noch. Salami. Nee, auch entfernt. FFZ.
FFZ hat das Salami nicht mehr. Kann das nicht euren Ernst sein, oder? Salami-Emote ist weg. Wir müssen unbedingt ein neues Salami-Emote suchen.
Ich fand das ehrlich gesagt lustig. Ich meine, gibt es wirklich Leute, die an so einem Emote getriggert sind? Das ist doch lustig.
Ich meine, das ist ein Frosch mit einer Salami. Natürlich ist uns allen klar, was damit gemeint ist. Aber das ist ja gerade der Gag da dran. Ich finde es nicht schlimm.
Na gut.
Obzien oder inappropriate Emotes? Okay. Obzien ist das. Obzien. Alles klar. Warum sind die Leute immer wegen allem so getriggert, Alter? Muss das echt sein?
Wir erlauben keine Obzien oder inappropriate Emotes.
Das stimmt.
Was willst du mit dem Router testen? Ja, das Gerät an sich. Kegwaid. Router. Also fangen wir mal an.
So Leute. Ja, haben wir noch irgendeinen Chat? Ich muss mal schnell gucken. Chat. Twitch at me. Ich habe doch auch mal sowas gebastelt.
Ich habe doch auch mal sowas gebastelt, was Chat-Messages mitlocken kann, was an mich geht. Das starten wir jetzt einfach mal.
Wie hieß das Ding? Pepega Board, oder? War das nicht das Pepega Board?
Das hatte so einen richtig... Net3 hieß das. Genau. Das hatte so einen richtig dummen Namen.
War es das? Oh fuck, Alter. Already in use. Ah nee, das ist es hier doch schon, oder?
Oh, ich glaube, das ist das Pepega Board, Leute. Schreibt mal was. Mal gucken, ob es aufploppt.
Nice. Mein Zeug funzt noch. Exzellent, exzellent.
So. Es lockt alles mit. Bam. Ach so, den Knopf habe ich nie implementiert. Da geht ja gar nicht. Lulwie.
Erstmal alles wieder gelöscht. Gibt es da jetzt Alternative? Ach, ich weiß nicht. Das muss ich alles löschen.
So, okay. Jetzt habe ich hier den Chatlock. Das ist schon mal gut. Der ist aus dem YouTube-Game weg. Okay, nice.
Falls ihr irgendwelche... Dann gehe ich jetzt noch mal ganz schnell den Chat durch, bevor ich das irgendwas übersehen habe.
Dann hat man auf die schnelle. Adwoblors. Ich glaube, so viel gab es da noch nicht. Warum neue Switche?
Weil ich die Geräte geil finde. Brauchen tue ich sie nicht wirklich.
Gab nichts, oder? Das hatten wir schon. Das Auspackvideo parallel aufnehmen. Exzhec, danke für den Sub. So, sehr schön. Auf geht's.
Massive. Massive Prane-Umfrage. Recursion-Umfrage. Das machen wir vielleicht später, aber jetzt...
Okay, ich warte noch eine halbe Stunde. Gut. Also, auf geht's. So, wir fangen mit dem Kleinen an.
Das hier ist der 8-Port-2-2-2-10-G-8-Port-1-G-Switch. Den machen wir jetzt erstmal weg. So, da ist er.
Erstmal den Stuhl hier hinter mir wegmachen, der ist ein bisschen im Wäsch. Also, Cloud-Switch-Series.
Gucken wir mal rein. Ich glaube, dass da kein Name irgendwie an Schrift oder sowas drauf ist, aber nee, ist nicht.
Alles klar, man weiß ja nie. Auf geht's. Gucken wir mal rein. Das Ding ist relativ klein.
Massive Handbuch dabei. Alles klar. Also, wer es nicht sofort lesen kann, ist eindeutig Huge Boomer.
Ich hoffe, ihr könnt das alle noch gut lesen. Also, wahnsinnig massive große Schrift. Vor allem das hier unten ist riesig groß.
Braucht eh keiner. Das funktioniert nicht. Ne, das klappt nicht. So, ähm. Haus da wegmachen.
Das Gametrain. Akku, danke schön für zwei Monate. So, das kommt weg. Das hier ist das Gerät. Und ich versuche jetzt euch mal die Features davon zu zeigen, soweit ich die noch aus dem Kopf weiß.
Ihr könnt auch gleich noch mal auf die Webseite gucken. So, das ist alles, was dabei ist. Der Switch bzw. der Router-Switch. Aber es ist eindeutig mehr ein Switch als ein Router.
Da hat es zwar Router-OS. Gucken wir uns gleich an. Und ähm. Aber der ist jetzt nicht dafür gedacht, irgendwie bei 10G sich Firewall regeln und Geroute und sonst was zu machen.
Er kann es, aber ist nicht dafür gedacht. So, und es ist ein Netzteil dabei. Das war's. Fertig. Mehr gibt's nicht. Leer ist. Guckt. Hier, da.
Nix drin. Erstmal in die Ecke pfeffern, das Teil. Bäm. Das ist da auch weg. Ähm. Hab Salami geupdatet. Nice. Aber du kannst es nicht hochladen. Bei BellaTwitchTV, die blocken das doch bestimmt.
Wie konntest du da was hochladen? Okay.
Etto Channel. Woop S. Salami. Exzellent. So, ich hab's geadded. Wenn ihr den Chat refresht, habt ihr wieder Salami. Je nachdem, wie schnell es das checkt.
Wobei, Moment. Woop S. geht nicht doppelt. Woop S. ist schon belegt. Woop S. ist für Smoke. Das geht nicht. Du musst das, du musst das, ähm. Du musst das umbenennen.
Woop S. ist schon belegt.
Nenn's Woop. Woop Wurst. Wurst. Nenn's Woop Wurst. Das ist gut. Woop Wurst.
Wie hast du das geschafft, da hochzuladen, ohne dass sie das genehmigen müssen? Hast du irgendwie nen Premium-Account oder so? Warum ist die Musik auf einmal so laut?
Okay, wunderbar. Geht's noch? Jawoll. Also.
Rotfilter. Okay.
Das Brillenlogo, das ist irgendwas von dem Kameraübertragungsding.
Musst du es neu adden?
Woop Wurst. Added to Channel. Woop Wurst ist drinne. Auf geht's.
Ähm, wir sollten das bei FFZ hochladen. FFZ hat mit dem Emote wahrscheinlich keine Probleme.
Ihr müsst aber Chat refreshen. Also angezeigt wird's, wird's noch nicht.
Okay, auf geht's.
Also. Wir haben dabei den Switch, den packen wir jetzt mal aus.
Und ich versuche euch natürlich Features zu zeigen, wie das Ding hat. Man sieht schon, sonderlich, sonderlich viel dran ist nicht an dem Teil.
Man bekommt hier ein ziemlich dünnes Teil. Switch mit 4 Ports SFP+. Die haben vorne immer solche Schutzklappen drinne.
Man muss sagen, so blöds klingt, man erkennt den Preis von dem Switch schon ein bisschen an den SFP Plus Schutzklappen.
Weil der 500 Euro teure Ubiquiti-Switch, der hat zum Beispiel schöne Gummischutzklappen.
Und der Mikrotik hat bloß so ganz billige AliExpress Schutzklappen.
Nicht, dass es in irgendeiner Art und Weise relevant wäre, aber so ist es halt.
So, also. 4x 10G Ports und einmal, den man auch per PoE benutzen kann, einmal einen 1 Gigabit Port.
Der ist, wie gesagt, der funktioniert ganz normal als normaler 1G Port, ist aber hauptsächlich auch für PoE gedacht.
Wenn man nicht das mitgelieferte Netzteil benutzen will und man hat einen PoE-Switch, kann man das hier drüber versorgen.
Ich habe keinen PoE-Switch, mit dem man das ausprobieren könnte jetzt.
So, weil PoE mit Mikrotik eh so ein bisschen komisch ist.
Vor allem, wenn du nicht Mikrotik Sachen noch mit verwenden willst.
Zum Beispiel kannst du damit halt nicht 48 Volt und 24 Volt gleichzeitig machen und so.
Aber wie gesagt, PoE habe ich eh, bis auf die Access-Pointen sich im Einsatz bei mir.
So, so sieht das Ding aus. Man sieht, mal zum Vergleich.
Ich lege euch mal den Raspberry Pi daneben, dass ihr so ungefähr die Größe einschätzen könnt.
Das Ding ist ziemlich klein.
Ah, der Mauszeiger, wartet mal.
Heck, wait.
So, also das Ding ist ziemlich klein. Guckt mal hier, Raspberry Pi daneben.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Also, der Switch ist nicht groß.
Der ist so eins, zwei, ein halb.
Na, noch mal einer.
So die Fläche von drei Raspberry Pies ungefähr.
Also man sieht, das ist nicht sonderlich groß.
Wird wahrscheinlich ein bisschen wärmer, weil das ist auch ein Feature.
Also was heißt ein Feature? Eher ein Geldspar-Feature bei denen.
Das Ding ist passivgekühlt, also da ist keine, da ist nichts drinne.
Und auch ein cooles Feature, was es in dieser Preisklasse selten gibt.
Zwei Netzteile.
Seht ihr das?
Man kann zwei Netzteile reinmachen.
Was schon ziemlich nice ist.
Ähm, wofür das hier ist, habe ich ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Zur Erdung oder so.
Da weiß ich es nicht.
So, und im Endeffekt, was das? Viel zu sehen gibt es da jetzt nicht.
Wir machen jetzt mal eine SFP-Plus-Port, die, den Einser.
Kommen wir mal raus, legen das da rein.
Und nehmen mal so ein, so ein Module.
Und so, das ist quasi euer AR45-Stecker hier.
Gucken, dass ich das Richtstrom reinmache.
Ja, ich habe es Richtstrom drin.
Guck hier, zack.
Einführen.
Und zack, so.
So sieht es dann aus, wenn es drin ist.
Und da kann man jetzt zum Beispiel so ein Glasfaserkabel nehmen.
Kann das Glasfaserkabel nehmen und kann das dann, wenn man die Kappe abgemacht hat, einstecken.
So, und so sieht das Ganze dann aus.
Also das ist quasi was anderes als man so kennt mit AR45-Kabel.
So sieht das mit Module und Glasfaserkabel aus.
Aber man kann das natürlich auch, wie gesagt, mit einem Direct-Attached-Kabel machen.
Das ist billiger, weil, das muss man vielleicht an der Stelle auch nochmal sagen.
Für längere Übertragungsstrecken.
Also wenn ihr jetzt zum Beispiel von eurem Serverraum, keine Ahnung, in Keller wollt oder ins Erdgeschoss oder sonst wo, je nachdem wo das ist.
Oh, was ist hier los?
Subscriptions, the fuck?
13, danke für die Sub.
Wie viele gibt es denn schon? 5 Stück?
Massive.
IQ des Chats wird da hier komplett am explodieren.
Wer hat denn was gekriegt?
Cutthots, Sanderwulf, Kampfkevin, PathosDev, HawkOps, HawkOps Gaming.
Danke schon für die gegifteten Subs.
Leute, falls ich irgendwas übersiehe, seht ihr es mir nach heute.
Ich muss auf zwei Sachen gucken.
Ähm...
Gut, äh, nee, nee, nee.
Bei Fabian spiele ich das eher nicht.
So, und...
Also sprich, wenn man längere Strecken überbrücken will, sag mal so alles ab 10 Meter vielleicht und dann vorbei.
Das muss man halt gucken.
Dann brauchen wir die Kombination aus SF4 Plus Modul und Glasfaserkabel.
Man kann allerdings, wie gesagt, was deutlich billiger ist, man kann einen Direct-Attach-Kabel nehmen.
Moment.
Man kann einen Direct-Attach-Kabel nehmen.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Jetzt fällt die Hälfte gleich wieder runter.
Und das vorne rein machen.
Das ist ein 7 Meter Direct-Attach-Kabel.
Das kostet 35 Euro.
So, und 35 Euro kostet normalerweise allein ein Modul.
Wenn es ein günstiges Modul ist.
Also das geht, das geht.
Danke schön, 11 Monate und M11 Pro, perfekt.
Huge Subs.
Also allein schon das Modul kostet mindestens 35 Euro.
Eins, ihr braucht ja zwei für beide Seiten.
Eher ein bisschen mehr sogar.
Und...
Also ich hab noch keine 10G.
Wo kriegst du denn für 13 Euro einen SFP Plus Modul?
Also die Mikrotik-Module gehen so ab 35 los.
Die Ubiquiti-Module gehen irgendwie so ab 40, 45 Euro los.
Und die Cisco und was gibt's noch?
Dell und sonst was gehen da noch teurer los.
Wish, Wish-Modul, ja.
Zumindest die bessere Variante ist auf jeden Fall,
wenn's günstig sein soll, sowas.
Ein Direct-Attach-Kabel 35 Euro, 7 Meter lang.
Da gibt's quasi die ganze Sache schon dabei.
Es ist quasi ein Kupferkabel.
Das hier ist ja unter anderem auch so teuer,
weil's Optik ist.
Also sprich, das ist SFP Plus auf Optik, also sprich auf Glasfaser.
Und das hier ist, tja, Kupfer im Endeffekt.
Da musst du nicht so viel machen, deswegen ist es auch billiger.
Ich glaub, ich hab's falsch rum.
Nee.
Und da kann man hier dran ziehen.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall billiger,
das mit dem Direct-Attach-Kabel zu machen.
Und...
Stimmt, wo kommt der Cursor her, what the fuck?
Versteh ich auch nicht, ich hab den nur rausgeschoben.
Ja, und das hier ist halt ein ganz normaler,
wie man ihn kennt, ein G-Port.
So, mehr gibt's jetzt von außen an dem Ding gar nicht zu zeigen übrigens.
Die Anzeigen sind hier vorne dran.
Hier ist noch mal ein Reset-Knopf.
Hier ist Strom, hier ist, frag mir nicht, Activity,
und hier sind die Ports-Geschichten.
Guckt man eh so gut wie nie drauf.
Ich würd sagen, bevor wir den jetzt anschließen und was machen,
packen wir den anderen auch noch mal aus.
Das hier mal kurz weg.
Tja, lass mal überlegen, was gibt's denn sonst noch so schönes dazu zu sagen?
Ich mach mal kurz hier den Ding wieder drauf.
Eigentlich nix.
So rein von außen gibt's dazu nicht wirklich was zu sagen.
Was ich gesehen hab ist, es gibt ganz coole 3D-Prints,
wenn man die in Rack einbauen will.
Da hab ich gesehen, hat einer ein 3D-Print gemacht,
so als Unterlage für so ne Schublade.
Da kann man drei MikroTik-Geräte draufsetzen von den Größen.
Ja, eigentlich ganz cool.
Ansonsten kannst du den nicht Rack-Mounten,
es sei denn, irgendjemand hat irgendwelche Rack-Mounted-Halterungen gebastelt dafür.
Würde mich nicht wundern, aber ganz ehrlich,
man braucht das auch, so ein kleines nicht, eine eigene Höhen-Einheit verschwenden.
Das kann man auf irgendeinen Untersatz stellen
und das mit zwei, drei anderen Geräten reinschieben.
Bist du holz für damals wegen dem Hemd?
So, was das da ist, hab ich ehrlich gesagt kein Plastenschimmer.
Ach, das ist hier die Stromkabelführung, guck.
Da kann man so machen, kann man Stromkabel reinmachen
und dann kann man das hier quasi irgendwie...
Das ist eigentlich ne coole Idee.
Ja gut, da muss man das abschrauben.
Kann man hier...
Kann man bestimmt irgendwie hier das Stromkabel...
Das Problem ist, ich seh nicht, weil das Elgato Ringlight mir voll ins Gesicht scheint.
So kann man das machen, ja.
Ich glaub, ich mach das jetzt richtig.
Mach das richtig, Chet?
So, und dann hängt das irgendwie nicht rum.
Eigentlich ne ganz coole Idee.
So, also, Switch Nummer eins, beziehungsweise Router.
Das hier ist tatsächlich ne vollfeatured Router beim MikroTik, zumindest was das Betriebssystem angeht.
Also sprich, da läuft RouterOS drauf.
Das hat alles, was MikroTik so zu bieten hat.
Von Firewall-Funktionen, DHCP-Server, irgendwie...
Na gut, VLAN-Config hat das andere auch.
Alles Mögliche, also alles, was RouterOS kann.
Aber wie gesagt, das Ding ist eigentlich mehr Switch als Router.
Es kann das zwar, aber vieles halt auch nur in Software über die CPU
und das kostet halt ordentlich Leistung.
Und wenn ich da ein paar Kleines dran hab, die wirklich mit 10G kommunizieren
und da ich da noch 50 Firewall-Regeln drauf hab, dann wird's wahrscheinlich ziemlich langsam.
Der kostet, glaube, aktuell, der ist relativ günstig.
Gucken wir mal.
Ich glaub, 120 oder so.
Ja, 120 Euro.
Das ist ein wirklich hammer Preis, ja?
Das ist ein echt hammer Preis.
Also 120 Euro, 4 Ports, 10G, ein Port, 1G.
Das kannst du dich nicht beschweren.
Und dual, dual, dual Power Supply und das Ganze passiv gekühlt.
Wir werden jetzt mal eine Sache machen, bevor ich den anderen auspack.
Ich stöpsel den mal ein und wir gucken mal schnell, wie viel Strom das Ding verbraucht.
Ich hab hier nämlich so ein... Ich hoffe, man sieht das irgendwie.
Chat, erkennt man da was?
Sieht man da was?
00 steht da drauf, sieht man, ne?
So, das kann natürlich sein, dass er jetzt erstmal ein bisschen mehr braucht,
weil er sich set-upen muss und sonst was.
Ich will einfach mal einstöpseln und mal gucken, wie viel er verbraucht.
So, 4,1. Also die Dinger verbrauchen auch nicht mal viel.
Der kann aber auch nicht viel verbrauchen, weil der ist passiv gekühlt.
Also sprich, der hat keinen Lüfter oder sowas drin.
So, man sieht, der ist an.
Genau, 4,2 Watt. Also das ist ziemlich low power.
Wir gucken uns das Ganze dann auch mal an, wenn er ein bisschen was überträgt.
Für was brauchst du denn das Teil? Erstmal haben.
Haben, beste.
Gut, jetzt haben wir den.
Machen wir erstmal wieder aus.
Und jetzt würde ich sagen, packen wir mal den anderen.
Packen wir mal den anderen aus.
Auf den anderen bin ich ja persönlich mehr gespannt,
weil den da hab ich mir mal geholt vor über einem Jahr.
Den wollte ich eigentlich ein Video drüber machen und dann verlosen.
Aber das war die Zeit, wo ich nie Videos gemacht hab.
Und deswegen hab ich den immer noch.
Können wir vielleicht mal im Stream zeigen.
Den anderen Switch hab ich mir tatsächlich geholt,
dass ich ihn verwenden kann und bei mir am Schreibtisch.
Jetzt verlosen. Nee, nee, nee, nee.
So, machen wir den erstmal weg.
Und jetzt kommt der huge Switch Champ.
Ich mach den Kram erstmal wieder weg hier, weil ich brauch Platz.
Huge.
100G auf dem Schreibtisch, ja.
Ich mach 100G an meinen Switch im Serverraum.
Und dann mach ich die 1G an die ganzen Geräte hier dran.
Also ich hab da quasi einen 10G-Ablink.
Und mein Rechner kommt an den Switch.
Und dann mach ich die 1G an die ganzen Geräte hier dran.
Ich hab quasi einen 10G-Ablink. Und mein Rechner kommt an den 2. 10G-Port.
Also genauso, was ich brauch.
Deswegen hab ich mir den geholt.
So, also. Wie emote bent? Wirklich?
Können wir das nicht bei FFZ hochladen?
FFZ band den Kram nicht.
Wird das Teil warm? Das werden wir gleich mal ausprobieren.
Okay, also.
Hier, so. Mal kurz gucken, ob da nicht wieder Adresse oder so draufsteht.
Sonst ist es leak.
Leak as fuck.
Nope. Passt, okay.
Auf geht's.
So. Wir haben wieder.
Auch diesmal haben wir, guck mal, guck mal.
Wir haben ein richtig echtes Manual hier. Seht ihr das?
Massive Manual in ultra-nicer Schriftgröße wieder.
Gucken wir mal, ob irgendwas erkennt.
Ja, okay. Aber es ist wirklich klein.
Brauch eh kein Mensch.
Erst mal weg damit.
So, was gibt's denn hier dabei? Schraubsorn.
Netzteil.
Ah, ich hab gar nicht geguckt, was das für eine Schriftgröße ist.
Moment, das müssen wir mal schnell schauen.
Der andere hat ein, ich vermute mal, das ist das Gleiche, ehrlich gesagt.
Der hat ein...
24 Volt, 800 milliampere.
Ja.
24 Volt, 800 milliampere Netzteil.
Mal gucken, was der andere hat.
Ich geh mal davon aus, dass es das Gleiche ist.
Mal gucken, was der andere hat. Ich geh mal davon aus, dass es das Gleiche ist.
So, packen wir mal das Netzteil aus und gucken, was das ist.
Das ist ein...
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Wer hätte das gedacht? 24 Volt, 800 milliampere Netzteil.
Thank you for the sub. Also genau das Gleiche Netzteil.
Was cool ist, da können wir nämlich bei dem anderen Switch
Dual Power Supply Input testen gleich.
So.
Dann packen wir mal aus. Oh, was ist denn das?
Leute, was sind...
Poggers!
Die hatten ein Rack-Mounted Kit dabei.
Seht ihr das?
Das ist ja Massive.
Damit hätte ich nicht gerechnet, ganz ehrlich.
Guck mal, die haben ein Rack-Gedöns dabei.
Moment, wartet mal.
Der Rack-Champ ist am Start.
Seht, guckt euch an, der Rack-Champ, Alter.
Übrigens, das Weiße sieht bei euch überhaupt nicht richtig weiß aus.
Sieht eher so braun aus oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaub, das iPhone macht komische Weißabkleidung.
Sondern nicht hochwertig fühlt sich dieses Rack-Ding allerdings nicht an.
Okay, nice.
Haben wir das am Start?
Hier gibt es noch mehr.
Oh, cool, guck mal, die haben ein komplettes Rack-Mounted Kit dabei.
Das finde ich cool.
Das hätten sie bei dem anderen auch machen können.
Aber man darf nicht vergessen, der hier kostet 85 Euro.
Das ist der Witz.
Ich kann mal kurz die Lampe umstellen.
Warte mal, wir stellen mal kurz das Licht von der Lampe um.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das irgendwie eine Auswirkung hat.
Ich glaube, sieht das jetzt weißer aus?
Ich glaube, so ist besser, oder?
Also bei mir sieht das jetzt viel blauer aus.
Ist besser, ne?
Oh, jetzt habe ich ausgeschaltet.
So ist gut.
Ja, lassen wir es mal so.
Lassen wir es mal so.
Also, ähm, gut.
Gucken wir uns das Rack-Mounted-Ding noch mal an.
Die haben aber ganz schön schnell das Emote gebannt, ne?
Chain-Lore.
Du hast es hochgeladen ins Emote, Alter.
Okay, eine Runde Rack-Mounted.
Okay, es fühlt sich, also Leute, das fühlt sich ein bisschen an wie Gips.
Es ist Metall, aber es fühlt sich ein bisschen an wie Gips.
Sonderlich, sonderlich high quality, super stabil ist es nicht.
Oh, oh.
Also, ich sollte da nicht dran rumdrücken.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht sonderlich stabil.
Aber das macht nichts.
Es ist auf jeden Fall ultra nice, das Mikro-Tick für einen 85-Euro-Switch,
der auch so schon absolut preis-leistungs-Poggers ist, das dabei gemacht hat.
Da kann man sich echt nicht beschweren.
Das ist wirklich äußerst, äußerst nice.
Wie ist eigentlich die Helligkeit?
Kann ich hier noch ein bisschen ändern?
Das Lustige ist, so ist es heller, so ist es heller,
aber die Farben sehen kacke aus, ne?
So sind die Farben besser, aber es ist dunkler.
Muss ich das jetzt verstehen in irgendeiner Art und Weise?
Ja, bei euch, aber bei mir ist das andere viel heller.
So, ich weiß auch nicht, was der mit dem Mauszeiger für Probleme hat, ehrlich gesagt.
Warum der immer den Mauszeiger in die Mitte macht.
Basisco kostet nur die Wreck-Mounts 85 Euro.
Ja, der Scheiß ist teuer, Basisco.
Deswegen sagen manche Leute auch Schisco.
Aber das sagen die absichtlich, nicht weil es...
Also unabsichtlich, die denken, das spricht man so aus.
Cisco, Cisco gibt es auch noch, Cisco.
Cisco, Schisco, Cisco, habe ich alles schon gehört.
Genauso wie Git, Alter.
Git, Jit, Jeit, was auch immer alles.
Spricht jeder irgendwie anders aus.
Okay, zuerst mal hier die...
Oh fuck.
Erst mal die Kiste wegmachen.
Alter, stinkt das.
Alter, was haben die da reingeschmissen?
Alter Leute, das riecht...
Das riecht wie Kuhscheißen Dünger auf dem Feld, was da rauskommt.
Kennt ihr das, wenn ihr an so einer frisch gedüngten Wiese vorbeilauft?
So riecht das, was da rauskommt, Alter.
Nee, das ist kein China-Gram.
Kommt aus Lettland, glaub.
Lettland, es ist.
Okay, ich mach das mal schnell raus.
Und dann mach ich die Tüte zu.
Tütenchamp, Giste weg.
Also, da ist er.
Cloudswitch, guck mal bei dem.
Also, die Bemalung fühlt sich wirklich nicht gut an.
Also, das fühlt sich an, als hätte es einer lackiert.
Aber nicht danach irgendwie noch sauber geschliffen oder so.
Fühlt sich total...
Ja...
Rau an, auf jeden Fall.
Aber gut, ich meine, das ist ein Switch, der kommt ins Surferschrank und dann ist Ruhe.
85 Euro, ja, kannst du nicht beschweren.
Also, Features.
Dual Power Supply sieht man bloß nicht.
Es hat einen Anschluss.
Aber angeblich Intel Dual Power Supply.
Wir können mal reingucken, wenn ihr wollt.
Wollen wir mal reingucken?
Wollen wir mal gucken, wie das Ding von innen ausschaut?
Weil wir schon dabei sind, man...
Bevor wir ihn anschließen, können wir mal reingucken.
Wie guckt man da überhaupt rein, hier unten das abmachen?
Wie macht man das auf?
Hier, hier vielleicht? Nee, hier, das ist Erdung.
Hier, hier macht man das auf, würde ich sagen, da.
Dann...
Guck mal, gut, dass ich den passenden Dreher dabei hab.
Exzellent.
Und dafür sind diese Fächer hier auch richtig nice.
So.
Fächerchamp.
Gucken, ob er jetzt aufgeht.
Oh, es knackst.
Ah nee, daneben sind auch noch welche, guck mal.
Ah, noch aufmachen.
Gucken wir einfach mal rein.
Das ist ja wieder typisch, ne?
Neues Gerät, das erste, was man erstmal aufschrauben.
Erstmal aufschrauben.
Scheißegal, was funktioniert, erstmal aufschrauben.
Öffnungschamp.
Jetzt aber, haha.
Da ist nicht viel drin.
Guck mal, hier sieht man auch, die haben es gespraypainted so irgendwie.
Guck, das ist...
Ja, keine Ahnung.
So, also, es ist nicht viel drin.
Erstmal übertakken.
Also, was haben wir hier zu bieten?
Das sind die Ports.
Das sind die 1G-Ports.
Das sind die SFP-Plus-Ports.
Also, ich zeig das mal so, besser vielleicht.
So sehen die Dinger immer aus von innen.
Diese Röhren, diese Plastikröhren, die ihr hier seht, ist für die LEDs.
Die LEDs sind irgendwo da unten.
Und über diese Plastikröhren gehen die LEDs dann hier hin.
Die SFP-Plus-Dinger sind eigentlich normal.
So, das sind die ganz normalen 1Gbit-Ports.
Mit Mac und sonst was, warum auch immer.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, hier ist die CPU drunter.
Das Ding hat nicht umsonst einen...
Kleinstpassivkühler.
Und ansonsten habe ich ehrlich gesagt keinen Plastenschimmer.
Aber es ist im Endeffekt nichts drin.
Also, die scheinen mir recht kosteneffizient gebaut werden zu können, ja.
Gibt es nichts Großartiges zu sehen.
Da können wir uns also auch sparen, den anderen aufzumachen,
weil damit auch nicht viel mehr drin sein.
Ist der managt? Ja.
Ja, klar. Also, du musst den selbst managen.
So, dann machen wir das mal wieder zu.
Ich bin ja bei sowas immer faul.
Und wenn ich jetzt nicht im Stream on wäre...
Scheiße, ich sehe das wegen dem Licht gar nicht richtig.
Wenn ich jetzt nicht im Stream on wäre, würde ich wahrscheinlich nur eine Schraube reinschrauben und dann aufhören.
Aber wir sind ja ordentlich, wir sind im Stream, wir machen das jetzt richtig zu.
Maybe geht es jetzt Wubwurst.
Okay, Moment.
Add to my channel.
Okay, wir haben Salami-Ersatz.
Refresht, mal Wubwurst haben wir jetzt.
FFZ-Emote, ist jetzt ein Keks mit Wurst.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der schon gesüngt hat.
Hat der schon gesüngt? Wubwurst?
Geht es bei euch schon?
Also, ich glaube, der hat den FFZ noch nicht gesüngt, aber der ist auf jeden Fall, das Emote ist auf jeden Fall nice.
Wer es nicht sehen kann, dem zeige ich das jetzt mal.
So sieht das Emote jetzt aus.
Okay, ich schraube den Kram jetzt mal schnell wieder zu.
Jetzt hätte ich mal meinen ordentlichen, man wäre Elektriker-Set am Start, dann hättest du das zackig drinnen und hättest du rumgefuddelt hier mit diesem kleinen Ding, was eigentlich da überhaupt nicht dafür gedacht ist.
Ah.
Alter Monkeys.
Geh nein.
Mein Problem ist auch, ich sehe nur die Hälfte wegen diesem scheiß Ringlight, Alter.
Ich mach das gerade nach Gefühl. So, passt.
Zu ist, nächste Schraube.
So, und dann machen wir das mal an und gucken uns das an.
Wir gucken uns wieder den anderen zuerst an, weil Chet hat ja abgestimmt und hat gesagt, wir wollen den anderen zuerst angucken.
Dann gucken wir den anderen auch zuerst an.
Aber den machen wir erstmal zu wieder.
So.
Übrigens, diese Sorte Schraubendreher sind ultra nice.
Ich wollte mir noch das Vera-Feinmechaniker-Set kaufen, weil die nochmal noch mal nicer sind.
Aber das Coole an diesen ist, du hast halt oben so ein Ding, was dreht, das heißt du kannst das dann so nehmen, die Hand drauf machen und kannst halt so drehen.
Guck.
Kannst dann quasi so drehen, weil du oben die Hand auflegen kannst.
Das ist sehr praktisch für so kleinen Scheiß.
Okay, das, okay verstehe.
Das sind die Schrauben zum, zum Rack-Mounten.
Scheint mir auch ganz sinnvoll.
Okay, also machen wir den mal weg.
Und nehmen wir mal den anderen und schließen den mal an und probieren mal aus.
Auf geht's.
Zack, Switchchamp.
Ich brauche Netzwerkkabel.
Ich überlege gerade, wie ich das jetzt mache.
Weil übers Webinterface ist nicht so gut.
Ich würde sagen, wir stöpseln den mal ans Netzwerkkabel an.
An das hier.
Nehmen wir mal das.
Dafür, dafür ist er ja auch da.
Gigabit, Gigabit-Management-Port.
So, dann würde ich sagen, stelle ich den mal so irgendwie hin, sodass der nicht umfällt.
Und wir machen das dran.
Und dann gehen wir, loggen wir uns mal drauf ein.
Ach so, was ist denn die Fault, die Fault-IP?
Die Fault-IP braucht man nicht mit dem Management-Tool.
Den findet ihr über die Mac-Adresse.
So.
An ist.
Wenn er hochgefahren ist, sollte jetzt irgendwann hier Port Link Activity kommen.
Ich hoffe, der kann sich sünden, weil dieses Kabel hängt auf der anderen Seite.
An einem SFP Plus auf AJ45-Adapter.
Mal gucken.
Die Dinger brauchen meistens ein bisschen zu booten.
Also sie sind nicht so ultra, ultra geschwind.
Ach so, man sieht glaube ich gar nicht.
Man hat hier gar nichts, man sieht hier gar nichts, ne?
Ich sehe auch keinen Link oder sonst was.
Weiß gar nicht, ob der standardmäßig on ist.
Vielleicht müssen wir echt per SFP Plus...
Ah, hier, guck mal, da.
Er ist hochgefahren, alles klar.
Sehr gut.
Exzellent.
Dann switchen wir mal auf die Leerungskiste rüber und gucken, ob man erkennt.
Zack.
Der ist top.
Ganz ehrlich, ich würde mir lieber einen bisschen günstigeren kaufen.
Den auf so eine Schublade packen mit deinem DSL-Modem und der Fritzbox und noch irgendwas zusammen.
Anstatt zu gucken, dass der wirklich unbedingt 19 Zoll mountbar ist.
So, schauen wir mal, habe ich Winbox drauf?
Winbox, natürlich nicht.
Also, die Dinger haben drei verschiedene Managementmöglichkeiten.
Diese Mikrotik-Dinger.
Die kann man über Webinterface managen.
Die kann man über Commandos-Teile managen.
Und die kann man über Winbox managen.
Das ist im Prinzip das Webinterface nur besser.
So, und ich werde das über Winbox machen, weil...
Oh, ich habe noch einen Snapshot, den muss ich mal löschen, der wird immer größer.
Delete, yes.
Jetzt werde ich es über Winbox machen, weil Winbox kann die Switche über Layer 2 discoveren.
Also sprich, du musst einfach nur am gleichen Switch hängen und der erkennt das.
Wohingegen das Webinterface natürlich konfiguriert...
What the fuck?
Muss ich ein Update machen?
Warte mal, ich muss ein Update machen.
Das wäre jetzt natürlich äußerst unpraktisch.
Dass ich erst mal Updates downhauen muss.
Aber es geht ja schnell.
Das ist ja das Schöne an Arch Linux, die Updates gehen immer wahnsinnig zackig.
Im Vergleich zu Ubuntu oder Debian oder...
Noch schlimmer, Red Hat.
Meinst du, ein Pi 3 läuft stabil, wenn man darüber Sat-IP laufen lässt?
Keine Ahnung.
Stabil werden die Dinger laufen, ich weiß nicht, ob die Leistung reicht, je nachdem.
Also für Full HD, wenn du da was machen willst, mit dem Stream eher nicht.
Aber wenn du einfach nur weiterleiten willst, bestimmt, warum nicht, ja.
Okay, wir müssen erst mal updaten, habe ich gesehen, alles klar.
Ein Updaten wäre schnell, das geht meistens, sag ich.
Download Size 895 MB, nix.
Ich will jetzt die Emotes nicht doppelt adden.
Wubwurs, weil es bleibt jetzt bei FFZ und dann ist es dann halt das nächste Mal da.
Warum ist der Download gerade so langsam?
Weil was ist denn das hier?
FF?
Ich würde sagen, wir müssen mal neue Lists, neue Mirrors generieren, weil das halte ich so nett aus.
Warte mal, wie ging das?
Mirror? Pac-Man Mirror?
Oh, wie ging das?
Refresh.
Jetzt weiß ich aus dem Kopf, wie der Kram funktioniert.
Rank.
What the fuck? Nee, das ging ganz anders.
Mal gucken, ob es jetzt schneller geht.
Also manche Sachen mache ich so selten, kann ich mir nicht merken, also.
Pac-Man Mirror.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das geht.
Man musste, man konnte die ranken, warte mal.
Wir müssen jetzt mal die Package-List aktualisieren, das wird ja sonst nix.
3.1.
Bis bei Speed.
Echt ging das so?
Wir machen das anders.
Pac-Man Mirrors.
Moment, wo werden die Dinger gespeichert? Pac-Man die Mirror-List.
Pac-Man die Mirror-List.
Ah, hier.
Man kann.
Der versucht gerade aus Frankreich zu laden.
Agile freut sich bestimmt.
Bam.
Guckt euch das mal an, jetzt plutscht es.
Einfach die Franzosen rausgeschmissen.
40 mb die Sekunde, auf gehts.
So Monster, Porgers, Frankreich minus minus.
Habt ihr mitgekriegt, die Bahn hat Probleme, weil so viel Schnee liegt.
Ich frag mich immer, wie man jedes Jahr vom Wintereinbruch Mitte Februar so überrascht werden kann.
Plötzlich der Wintereinbruch mitten im Winter Mitte Februar, wer hätte damit nur rechnen können.
Ist genauso wie unser Breitbandausbau.
Wer hätte damit nur rechnen können, dass es nicht klappt bis 2025.
Niemand.
Die vier Feinde der Deutschen Bahn.
Ja, Frühling, Sommer, Herbst und Winter.
Allerdings hat der Witz auch schon so ein Bart.
Okay, auf, mach Update.
Let's go.
Hopp hopp.
Ich muss den anderen Crab installieren.
Hat der die Snapshots gelöscht.
Was für eine Anbindung, 400 runter, 40 ab.
Ja.
Das ist doch bei Unity Media.
Vodafone ist aber schon permanent dran und will mir permanent was Neues aufschmerzen.
Ja, Kabel, ja gut.
Gibt ja sonst keine Möglichkeiten mehr.
VDSL ist ja mehr oder weniger am Ende.
Mit 250 MBit.
Ja, ich weiß, dass es theoretisch noch schneller geht.
Aber das werden die meisten wahrscheinlich nie zu Gesicht bekommen.
Nee, das ist Vodafone jetzt, aber ich habe es noch bei Unity Media abgeschlossen.
Starlink ist was, also ich finde es nice, wie Elon Musk das hinkriegt.
Mit Tesla und Raketenstellen und sonst was.
Aber es gibt zwei Produkte von ihm, da glaube ich echt nicht dran.
Und zwar ist das einmal diese U-Bahn Geschichte und Starlink.
Also da würde ich mir keine Aktien kaufen.
Wohingegen ich mir Tesla Aktien würde ich mir holen oder hätte ich mir holen sollen, besser gesagt.
Da glaube ich auch dran, dass das was Gutes ist und funktioniert und auch immer besser funktionieren wird.
Aber an Starlink und Hyperloop oder wie das heißt, glaube ich nicht.
Starlink ist doch für die dritte Welt gedacht.
Kann man sich jetzt darüber streiten?
Es gibt ja die Vermutung, dass es für High Frequency Trading verwendet wird.
Weil die Verbindung per Satellit schneller ist von sagen wir nach New York nach Frankfurt.
Und dass es im Prinzip für Stonks Leute im Endeffekt hauptsächlich genutzt wird.
Starlink in einzelnen, das Problem ist, du kannst eine einzelne Sache zwar testen, das funktioniert ganz gut.
Das sagt aber nichts darüber aus, wie das funktionieren wird, wenn das mal wirklich viele Leute verwenden.
Du kannst relativ schnell an die Bandbreitengrenze zwischen verschiedenen Satelliten kommen,
wenn du da mal wirklich viele Leute damit verbindest.
Das glaube ich nicht, dass das gut funktionieren wird.
Aber ich lasse mich ja gerne eines Besseren belehren, aber ich glaube es nicht.
Was hat da was gefailt?
Da hat nichts gefailt, alles klar.
Yes.
Stonks, jawoll.
Okay, so und jetzt starten wir Winbox und konfigurieren den Switch.
Was ist deine Lieblingsmarke bei Enterprise Switches?
Ganz ehrlich, Enterprise Switches kenne ich mich nur mit Cisco-Dingern halbwegs aus.
Das ist auch schon Jahre her.
So, da sind wir, Winbox.
Übrigens, es läuft über Wine, nicht erschrecken.
Dieses Switch-Config-Software ist eigentlich nur Windows-Only, aber funktioniert mit Wine echt gut.
Nee, Winbox ist die offizielle Konfigurationssoftware von Mikrotik.
Wie gesagt, du kannst die Dinger über drei verschiedene Varianten konfigurieren.
Web-Interface, Kommandozeile oder Winbox.
Winbox funktioniert einfach am besten.
Auf starken Blitz.
Übrigens, ein nicees Hintergrundbild haben wir da heute.
Sollte der nicht eigentlich was discoveren?
Ah, hier.
Das ist meine, meine normale.
Und das ist der...
Connect.
Ach nee, was ist denn das Standard-Passwort?
Okay, ich habe das eben nicht mehr gemacht.
Die Fortpasswort.
Okay.
Admin-No-Password.
Moment, geht das etwa nicht da drüber?
Jetzt ernsthaft?
Muss ich mich da jetzt direkt anstöpseln, dass das funktioniert?
Ja gut, dass wir unseren Raspberry Pi haben.
Ah, IP-League-Lull.
Ich dachte, er kann das über Layer 2 machen.
Das kann er nicht.
Aber discoveren kann er ihn.
Sehr schön.
Ich kann mir einfach eine IP geben.
Ich kann mir einfach eine zweite IP adden aufs Interface.
Was weiß ich aus dem Kopf, Alter.
Add, second, IP, Linux, IP add.
Ah, Restart required.
Firefox ist RIP.
Du musst auf die Mac klicken?
Wie?
Und jetzt connect.
Ach, what the fuck?
Habe ich das nicht gemacht?
Hä?
MonkaS?
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
Ah, okay.
Also, was will er jetzt?
Switch Mode.
All Interfaces switched.
LAN-Configuration.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was du von mir willst.
Jaja, aber alle Ports switched ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
So.
Und die Sache ist die, das ist das komplette Router-OS, was da drauf steht.
Du kannst mit diesen Mikrotik-Dingern unglaublich viel machen.
Also, das ist, das ist massive Verwirrung pur, was man da machen kann.
Da muss man sich echt mal eine Weile mit auseinandersetzen, dass man dahinter kommt.
Also, hier kann man zum Beispiel die Adresse ändern.
Das werde ich jetzt mal machen.
Und zwar, ich stelle dich jetzt mal auf eine lokale IP ein, dass ich draufkomme.
Kann Mikrotik eigentlich mittlerweile WireGuard?
Die haben, glaube ich, eine Custom-Firma, die das kann.
Ich bin per com drin.
Ja, ja.
Also, nicht per com, per Layer-2-Connection über Winbox.
So.
Also, sprich, man kann total viel machen.
Du kannst vom DHCP, DNS bis Firewallen regeln.
Du kannst hier Interfaces, WLAN-Gedöns einstellen.
Also, Router-OS ist übelst komplex.
Das Problem ist nur, dass es nicht sonderlich intuitiv ist.
Du kannst alles Mögliche machen, aber es ist nicht so, es ist nicht so ohne.
Also, wie man Firewall-Regeln einrichtet, Marzia kann ich dir zeigen.
Aber, nee, das ist sonderlich anwenderfreundlich in Form von Easy, ohne nachzugucken.
Das machen ist es nicht, nee.
Aber, also, Firewall-Regeln kann ich dir zeigen, aber WLANs auf dem Router kann ich dir nicht zeigen.
Das ist eine Wissenschaft für sich.
Da muss ich immer selbst Tutorial nachgucken.
Für WLANs auf dem Router musst du nämlich erst irgendwie einen neuen Port adden oder irgendwie sowas.
Dann musst du irgendwie einen WLAN adden mit der jeweiligen WLAN-ID.
Dann musst du dir eine extra Interface für anlegen.
Das ist total wirr.
Das ist mit Switch-OS wohl wirklich besser.
Und Firewall-Regeln sind einfach anzulegen.
Gehst einfach hier hin in die Firewall-Config, sagst Add und stellst ein, was du haben willst.
Source-IP, Destination-IP, Protokoll.
Also, Firewall-Regeln sind relativ selbst erklären.
Du kannst zum Beispiel sagen, keine Ahnung, Source-Adresse, Punkt 0 Punkt, Slash 24.
Keine Ahnung, Protokoll, TCP, Destination-Port 5000 und Out-Interface auf SFP plus 3 oder sowas.
So, dann kannst du das hinzufügen und dann Firewall das.
Kannst du zeigen, wie man Subnetze pro Port definiert?
Äh, was? Hä?
Du meinst mehrere IPs auf dem gleichen Port?
Kein Schimmer.
Weil du kannst wahrscheinlich in Addresses sagen, du willst mehrere anlegen.
Oh, bricht ja nichts dagegen. Probier mal aus.
Was ist denn frei hier? 86 ist glaube ich frei.
Muss man da? Nee.
Oh, jetzt hast du zwei IPs auf dem Interface. Mal gucken, ob was pingen kann.
Oh, geht nicht. 0W.
Hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gedacht, dass es funktioniert.
Tja, kein Schimmer.
Ähm, ich bin auch nicht der Pro, was RouterOS angeht.
RouterOS ist halt nicht so ohne.
Bis man das erstmal gecheckt hat, dauert eine Weile.
Oh, Subnet ist falsch. Tatsächlich.
Wie muss man das jetzt angeben?
Jetzt hat er es gecheckt.
Guck jetzt die IP auch da.
Das ist die 3WM.
So, und jetzt hast du zwei IPs auf dem gleichen Interface.
Pro Anschluss ein Subnetz, ja so, hier.
Such dir einen Port raus.
Such dir einen Port raus und vergeb eine IP.
Wobei man hier gucken muss, aktuell ist das Ding ja eingestellt auf reinen Switch-Modus.
Also sprich, alles hängt an dieser Bridge dran. Das kann man auftrennen.
Allerdings, und das ist halt die Sache,
hast du dann das Problem, dass das wahrscheinlich nicht mehr über die interne Hardware,
über den internen Hardware-Switch läuft und langsamer ist.
Deswegen, das Ding ist, obwohl es RouterOS drauf hat und sich Dinger kann,
eigentlich eher ein Switch.
Weil jetzt ist der Port auch egal.
Also sprich, egal welchen Port ich nehme, es sind immer beide IPs verfügbar.
Also es ist wurscht, ob ich mich jetzt hier an den Port stöpsel oder hier oben an den Port stöpsel.
Also die IPs liegen auf der Bridge für alle Ports.
Du müsstest quasi die Bridge erstmal wieder auftrennen in einzelne Ports, wenn man das machen will.
Würde ich aber für den Switch nicht machen.
Bei einem Router ist es kein Ding, da ist es standardmäßig so.
Also bei meinem Router hat jedes Interface eine extra IP.
Aber wie gesagt, das Ding ist halt so eingestellt, weil es auch erstmal hauptsächlich der Switch gedacht ist.
So, also wie gesagt, das ist RouterOS.
Damit könnt ihr nahezu alles machen, was irgendwie geht.
Ihr könnt die übelsten abgedrehten Sachen machen, ihr könnt MPLS Tunnel machen, ihr könnt IPSEC machen,
OpenVPN, sogar eigene BGP-Geschichten ausprobieren lokal.
Man kann da wirklich alles Mögliche mit machen.
Im Zweifelsfall kann man da drüber auch Command- und Zeilen-Config machen.
Aber es ist nicht auf einer halben Arschpacke gemacht.
Also es ist nicht so einfach.
Also wie gesagt, so Sachen wie Firewall-Regeln und Adressen anlegen sind noch halbwegs selbsterklärend.
Der DHCP-Soft war es auch noch halbwegs selbsterklärend, wenn ihr wollt, dass das Ding IPs vergibt.
Die WLAN-Config ist schon wieder eine ganze Ecke komplizierter.
Aber man kann echt verdammt, verdammt viel mitmachen.
Also das ist RouterOS, exellent.
Jetzt können wir uns mal gucken, ob wir uns auf ein Webinterface einloggen können.
Ja, da sind wir.
Und wenn man sich über das Webinterface das erste Mal einloggt,
kriegt man auch so einen Mini-Quick-Guck.
Hier, U-Mode, hier kannst du übrigens auch umschalten zwischen Router-Mode und Switch-Mode.
Aber man will das Ding eigentlich nicht defaultmäßig im Router-Modus betreiben.
Das ist hauptsächlich den Switch.
Das ist wie gesagt auch, das hat gar nicht die CPU,
um irgendwie 10G da in Echtzeit durchzuruhten mit Firewall-Regeln dazwischen.
Sowas kannst du vergessen.
So, also, ist das dann Bridge oder Switch?
Das ist das Gleiche.
Ein Switch ist quasi eine Bridge mit mehreren Ports.
Das ist genau das Gleiche.
So, dann würde ich nämlich jetzt sagen,
jetzt kommen wir mal zu der anderen Sache.
Ich will mal gucken, ob das funktioniert mit den Ports,
ob das meine Module frisst.
Da muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Mir fällt gerade auf, ich kann das gar nicht ausprobieren,
weil ich keine SFP-Plus, keine Kiste mit SFP-Plus habe.
Aber wir können den Raspberry Pi ausprobieren mit dem 2,5G-Ding.
Also, das probiere ich jetzt nämlich mal aus.
Wir haben hier die 10G-Ports.
Ich werde das jetzt übrigens mal abziehen.
Dann verliere ich jetzt die Verbindung, weil ich brauche das gleich.
Ich muss jetzt nämlich gleich hinten zu meinem Server-Schrank
und das Modul rausziehen, wo das dran ist.
Und ich schließe mal, dass wir das Ding weiter managen können.
Ich schließe mal hier ein anderes Kabel dran an.
Von meinem Desktop-Switch.
Hoffentlich reicht das Kabel.
Warte mal Leute, ich hoffe das Kabel reicht.
Fuck yes.
So.
Ich kann die Mikrotik-Dinger miteinander verbinden,
aber damit kann ich nicht so viel ausprobieren.
Jetzt geht's los.
So.
Okay, wunderbar.
Also, ich habe es am Start.
Und zwar ein SFP-Plus auf R-Bot 45.
Da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt, ob das funzt.
Fangen wir erstmal rein.
Eigentlich kann ich das theoretisch direkt raus machen.
Wir gucken mal, ob es so funktioniert.
An der Port sollte sich hochfahren.
Da ist es.
Und jetzt testen wir das mit dem Raspberry Pi mal aus,
ob das klappt.
Pi am Start.
Pi-Netzteil am Start.
Dieser komische Crap-Adapter am Start.
Oder gucken wir mal, was das zynkt.
Es sind nicht immer alle SFP-Plus-Module.
Wenn du Pech hast, wenn du Pech hast nicht.
Normalerweise sollte das gehen.
Aber wenn du Pech hast, manchmal nicht.
So ein bisschen herstellerabhängig.
So, machen wir das hier dran.
Zack.
AUSCH-Netzwerk-Kabel.
RGB-Netzwerk-Kabel am Start.
Zack.
Fangen wir erst da dran.
So.
Oh fuck, wie kriege ich das jetzt?
Die Steckdosenleiste ist zu dünn.
Wartet mal.
Beziehungsweise, das ist zu fett.
Das ist zu Pepofett.
Übrigens, wir verbrauchen gerade 6,3 Watt.
Ich muss den Switch mal ausmachen.
Das ist zu...
Kein Platz.
Raspberry Pi dran stöpseln.
Ich verbinde mich auf den Pi jetzt per W-Lan.
So, ich gleich dabei.
Ich gehe da per W-Lan drauf.
Gucken, ob wir hier für Platz jetzt noch irgendwie haben.
Das.
Nee, fuck.
Passt nicht.
Doch, jetzt passt es sehr gut.
So, den Switch dran.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob da die Kombi erkennt.
Die ist jetzt schon sehr advanced, die Kombi.
Das ist ein SFP Plus auf AJ45-Modul an der USB 2,5G-Karte.
Wir machen auf jeden Fall auch mal ein Firmware-Update gleich noch.
Da habe ich so meine Zweifel, ob er das jetzt erkennt.
Schauen wir mal.
Pi add, ach nee, nicht Pi, Ubuntu add.
Der sollte die 150 als IP haben, wenn ich das ganz falsch leg.
Jubantu, da sind wir.
Ups.
Prediction wird es funktionieren, ich denke schon.
Also, if-config.
Der Raspberry Pi erkennt gerade schon mal gar nicht die Netzwerk-Karte.
Was ziemlich sackt.
Ziemlicher Müll ist.
Monkeys.
Wie das USB-Kabel ist bad.
Ich muss mich verarschen, das ging ja eben noch.
Wartet mal.
What the fuck?
Er blinkt auch.
Ah, jetzt geht es.
Okay, easy.
Okay.
2500 MBit, alles klar.
Ja, da ist er doch.
Excellent.
So, also.
Bester Name für eine Netzwerk-Karte auf jeden Fall.
Also, ich meine, er erkennt es schon mal.
So, if-config.
Geben wir dem Ding mal eine IP.
122168.
Was war da standardmäßig drauf?
88, ne?
So.
Ping.
88.1, jawoll, Funst.
Nice.
Also, erreichen kann er den Switch schon mal.
Das Switch ist halt sonst nicht so angestöpselt.
Deswegen muss ich mir da jetzt mal einen Firefox installieren,
dass wir per X-Forwarding draufkommen.
Big Brain Tactics.
So, das heißt, das Funst, das macht mich doch schon mal echt zuversichtlich.
Also, wenn das auch sinkt mit 2,5G.
Wir können mal gucken, was er übertragen kann.
Nee, können wir nicht, weil ich keine Gegenstelle dran habe,
mit der wir das ausprobieren können.
Ich könnte jetzt...
Ich könnte doch...
Wisst ihr, was ich mache?
Klar, deswegen habe ich das doch gekauft.
Alter, ich bin manchmal echt Monarch-S.
Guckt mal, ich habe doch dieses fette...
Deswegen habe ich mir das doch sogar gekauft.
Ich habe doch hier dieses fette Direct-Attach-Kabel.
Das nehme ich jetzt und stecke das an meinen Ubiquiti-Switch im Serverraum.
Das blaue Kabel ist zu kurz.
Das reicht halt hin.
Dann komme ich da nämlich auch wieder drauf.
Da können wir auch gleich sehen, dass das Funst.
Ok, während das installiert, wunderbar.
Da können wir nämlich auch gleich sehen, ob die Zusammenarbeit zwischen den Switchen geht.
Und wir machen dann ein Firmware-Update.
So, machen wir hier mal den Port noch ab.
Zack, ihr seht, das sind Module komplett am Kabel dran.
Da muss man nichts reinmachen.
Einfach anstöpseln und gut ist.
So, mal kurz Headset ab.
Einfach kurz in meinen Switch ein.
Komm!
So, und wenn wir Glück haben, sollte der jetzt den Port erkennen schon gleich.
Lass mal schauen.
Der Switch macht gerade gar nichts.
Eigentlich sollte der jetzt Port ab anzeigen.
An Port 1.
Das hier ist Port 1.
Lustigerweise, mein Ubiquiti-Switch hinten zeigt schon an, dass der Port ab ist.
Aber der zeigt weder, guck mal, der zeigt weder Port 4 noch irgendwie was anderes Port ab.
Hm, verdächtig, verdächtig.
Pi tot?
Nee.
Pi funzt noch.
Monkeys.
Hallo?
Kann nicht sein, ich hab eben schon mal Enter gedrückt.
Und das ist W-Lan.
Ich bin bei W-Lan auf dem Pi dran.
Der Pi kann überhaupt nicht tot sein.
Wie soll das gehen?
Ah, jetzt funktioniert's ja.
Aber hier oben geht's nicht mehr.
Okay.
Was auch immer.
Ah, das andere hängt noch.
So, schauen wir mal, ob wir...
Ah, guck mal!
Das funktioniert.
Aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen, Interfaces...
Guck, die ganzen RSFP-Plus-Dinger sind oben.
Aber warum wird denn kein Aktivitätslicht angezeigt?
Guck mal, die Ports sind angeblich alle nicht oben.
Obwohl sie oben sind.
Muss man das jetzt verstehen?
Wenn du halt kaputt...
Nee.
Ich mach mal ein Firmware-Update.
Schadet nix.
So.
Okay, das ist jetzt dumm.
Das ist immer noch gelockt, ne?
Ah, ich bin ja auch kein Root-Lol-W, hab ich vergessen.
Ah, jetzt geht's auch.
Na gut, der hat jetzt keinen Uplink.
Wobei doch, der hat natürlich WLAN-Uplink.
Firefox.
LED-Nummer 10G?
Das ist 10G.
Also die Verbindung ist 10G.
Hier auf dem...
Man erkennt es jetzt nicht so richtig wegen der Belichtung.
Wobei die Belichtung ist, das iPhone hat einen schlechten Abgleich irgendwie, ne?
Also hier, da ist kein Licht an, aber müsste eigentlich an sein.
Oh, der wird sogar ein bisschen warm.
Aber kannste knicken, also...
Ja, was auch immer.
Nee, nee, die Verbindung geht ja.
Die Verbindung geht ja, guck.
Verbindung ist okay.
Okay, Firefox ist installed.
Ich muss das eigentlich gar nicht machen.
Also, wir machen mal ein Firmware-Upgrade.
Nee, nee, es ist 10G.
Es ist 10G gesyncht.
Wo sieht man das nochmal, ob es 10G gesyncht ist?
Äh, boah.
Interface-List.
Port-Status.
Mal, wo sieht man nochmal, mit was das...
Mit was das gesyncht ist?
Hm.
Das ist immer ein bisschen versteckter Kram.
Okay.
Muss man irgendwie doppelt anklicken oder so?
Ich kann mich noch genau dran erinnern, wie es aussieht.
Also, wenn ich sehe, erkenne ich sofort, wo das gesyncht ist hier.
Okay, man kann es per Kommandozeile machen.
Man kann es garantiert im Webinterface machen.
Ich hab das schon gesehen, im Webinterface.
Weiß, dass das funktioniert.
Ich weiß bloß nicht, wo.
Ich weiß noch genau, wie das Fenster ausgesehen hat.
Aber ich hab keine Ahnung, wo es versteckt ist.
Wir können es ja mal...
Äh, ach so.
SFP plus eins gesyncht.
SFP-Connector Typ Copper.
Genau.
Rate 10G und jetzt haben wir 4.
Link 2,5G.
Alles klar.
Der erkennt das auch.
Passt.
Komm mal, der erkennt.
Aber eins ist schon mal echt gut zu wissen.
Die Dinger können auch 2,5G.
Was sehr praktisch ist, weil 2,5 und 5G ist das,
was ich auf dem Desktop durchsetzen wird.
Also, 2,5G Link.
Und das andere hat 10G zu meinem Switch.
Switch zu Switch-Verbindung.
Wunderbar.
Dann machen wir mal ein Firmware-Update.
System.
Das ist auch übelst versteckt.
Ich mach das einmal im Jahr oder so.
Tools.
Das war glaube ich System.
Packages oder irgendwie sowas.
Total versteckter Kram für Firmware-Update.
Wo war denn der Scheiß noch mal?
Also, ihr seht, Switch OS ist alles andere als selbsterklärend.
Irgendwo gab es Packages.
Ach hier, Packages.
Da ist es doch.
Genau.
So.
Check for Updates.
Install Version.
Ach so, Moment.
Der Switch hat keine Verbindung ins Internet.
Cack wait.
Das geht ja gar nicht.
Was macht Auto-Upgrade?
Ja.
Upgraden.
Das muss ich jetzt...
Okay, jetzt wird es komplizieren.
Jetzt muss ich dem Switch beibringen.
Geh mal ins Internet.
Das heißt, wir gehen jetzt auf DHCP.
DHCP Client.
Oh shit.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob ich das jetzt auf die Reihe kriege.
Okay, DHCP Client Interface.
Bridge ist durchaus okay.
Unter Quick...
Ja, Moment.
Unter Quick kann ich so eine Standard Setup machen, ne?
Aber wo ist Quick?
Quick Setup.
Ja, das ist das Standard Setup.
Das ist das Standard Setup.
Ne, ne, ne.
Genau.
Da kannst du hier nämlich einstellen.
Automatic.
IP und so.
Ne, ne.
Wir machen das jetzt mal von Hand.
Also.
Interface.
Bridge.
Kann ich übrigens verschiedene Interfaces einstellen?
Also wir wollen die IP.
Dann stelle ich halt mal ein Interface ein.
Ich hab's angeschlossen.
Also mein Uplink zum Router ist an Port.
Zum Switch.
Ist an Port hier, an dem da.
Das ist Port 1.
Port 1.
Ich dachte eigentlich, ich muss die Bridge angeben.
Aber okay.
Interface Port 1.
Interface.
Ja genau.
Deswegen ich muss Bridge angeben.
Hätte mich auch sehr gewundert, wenn ich.
Bridge.
Searching.
Bäm, er hat eine IP gekriegt.
Easy.
2 1 3 6.
Na das ist jetzt ja einfach.
Addresses.
Und jetzt sieht man es hier.
Guck.
Dynamic, deswegen ist ein D vorne dran.
Ähm, haben wir jetzt Dynamic IP gekriegt.
Das ist doch, ist doch gar nicht so einfach.
Okay, also, Tools.
Tools, Packages.
Alter, ist der Kram unübers...
Nee, nicht Tools, System, Packages.
Check for Updates.
Also...
IP League, MonkaS, oh nein.
I'm in.
Also, wir können updaten.
Guck mal, vom 3. Februar.
Dann updaten wir ihn mal.
Download und install.
Und wir gucken mal dann, ob die Links jetzt, ob die Links wieder on kommen.
Weil aus irgendwelchen Gründen...
...ist er ja der Meinung...
...in irgendwelchen Gründen ist er ja der Meinung...
...wir haben kein Bild.
Also kein Link...
...up, Link, down.
Lustigerweise hat Link up, Link down...
...beim 1 Gigabit sofort funktioniert.
Weil wir machen mal ein Filmware-Update.
Rebooting, gucken wir mal zu.
Beim Rebooten.
Ich glaube, zum 2. Switch kommen wir heute nicht mehr, Leute. Es ist ja fast schon 21 Uhr.
Ich schließe den jetzt mal an.
Leute, ich schließe jetzt den 2. an.
Auf geht's. Ich hab, ich hab kein...
...ich hab keinen Platz mehr.
Ich hab keinen Platz mehr für Strom.
Moment.
Ich hab da noch meine...
...special, halb kaputte China-Steckdosen-Leiste.
Bam.
China-Champ ist am Start.
Die muss ich nur noch einstöpseln, dazu muss ich den Raspberry Pi aber mal ausmachen.
Das ist die, wo ich gedacht hab, dass die kaputt ist.
Hast du noch einen Direct-Attach-Kabel?
Ja, ich hab noch ein paar.
Aber das einzige, was ich jetzt hier zum Greifen hab, ist angeschlossen.
Okay, der Raspberry Pi spackt rum.
Gucken wir mal beim Rebooten zu.
Ich mach den Raspberry Pi jetzt erst mal.
Erst mal raus.
Ab. Zack. Einfach ausschalten, easy.
Wow, ey, das Elgato-Netzteil wird ganz schön warm.
Die China-Steckdosen-Leiste ist übrigens mega im Arsch, ne?
Jetzt haben wir Glück, jetzt geht sie.
Die hat einen Wackelkontakt.
Wenn das Kabel falsch ist, guck mal.
Voll im Arsch, das Teil.
Richtiger Crap.
Okay.
Dann haben wir den Raspberry Pi hier dran.
Ist jetzt an? Ja, exzellent.
Und den anderen Switch, den machen wir da dran.
Ach, guck mal.
Der hat den Strom vorne.
Das fällt mir jetzt auch erst auf.
Das heißt, der hat hinten gar nichts.
Dann können wir den auch hochkant hier hinstellen.
Hups.
Und dann passt's.
Guck mal, bis sie balancieren das Ganze.
So.
Also der mag immer noch keine Links anzeigen.
Hat er keinen Bock drauf.
Juckt ihn nicht.
Aber wir werden die beiden jetzt verbinden miteinander.
Und nämlich per richtig
echtem
massive Glasfaser.
Und zwar
einmal Glasfaser mit Modul.
Zweimal Glasfaser mit Modul.
So.
Zack.
Abmachen.
Erstmal gleich Vollbestückung vom Switch hier.
Rein damit.
Und...
Hopp, ist richtig rum.
Na, ist falsch rum.
Und...
Rein damit.
Guck mal, der Funks.
Hier gehen die Linkanzeigen.
Da sind die Linkanzeigen kaputt.
Was ist mit meinen Linkanzeigen los?
What the...
Hm.
Verstehe ich nicht jetzt, aber okay.
Also die Dinger sind verbunden. Scheint zu funktionieren.
Erstmal ein Lack gehabt. Nee, aber das lag nicht da dran.
Okay, Firmware Update hat funktioniert.
Check for Updates.
Stream... Ernsthaft? Stream war weg?
Hä? Das kann aber damit nichts zu tun haben.
Das kann aber damit nichts zu tun haben, dass das Stream weg war.
Ernsthaft?
Vielleicht hat er irgendwelche
Klassenspannung-Tree-Geschichten gemacht.
Mein, mein, äh, Ubiquity-Switch.
Nee, nee, ich hab keinen zweiten DHCP an.
Was auch immer das Sache ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Der hat wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Spannung-Tree-Geschichten.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Der hat wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Spannung-Tree-Geschichten gemacht.
Kein Schimmer.
So. Also.
Updated ist es. Und wir sehen,
dass wir immer noch keine Links sehen. Wunderbar.
Aber hier der Link funktioniert.
Das heißt, jetzt kann ich den anderen Switch
auch einrichten.
Neighbors, refresh?
Hm.
Der sollte den doch jetzt eigentlich finden.
Macht er aber nicht.
Ab ist der Port.
Die sollten jetzt eigentlich geswitcht sein, also das sollte jetzt eigentlich keinen Unterschied
machen.
Ich meine, das ist alles mehr oder weniger ein großer Switch jetzt dadurch.
Mehr oder weniger.
Nö, da findet ihr nicht.
Ach fuck, das kann das ja nicht.
Stimmt, du kannst dich damit ja nicht connecten, das ist ja Switch OS.
Ok, wie komme ich denn da jetzt drauf?
Da muss ich wahrscheinlich per Webinterfäls drauf, oder?
Ok, wo ist der Raspberry Pi?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das äh, du meinst, ich soll den kleinen Strom losmachen, ob die
LEDs dann wieder gehen?
Der SFB Plus läuft, der Port ist ja oben und blinkt auch mit Aktivität.
Äh, nee, ich muss den Pi nicht anschließen, ich gebe mir einfach eine extra IP auf dem
Interface.
Aber, hat er jetzt nicht IP-Konflikt?
Ich muss das mal runter machen, der hat doch jetzt IP-Konflikt mit dem anderen Switch.
Der ist doch, Moment, der ist doch jetzt doppelt, die IP ist doch doppelte Default-IP.
Muss ich erst mal einstellen, dass der den Licht mehr verwendet.
Ähm, oh guck mal, es sieht jetzt moderner aus, oder?
Die, die Items sehen jetzt exquisiter aus.
Äh, also Interfaces, IP, Addresses, so, die muss weg, die muss, die muss weg, die IP.
Weil, die, die, sonst gibt's IP-Konflikt, schlecht, so, weg.
Okay, wir Rebooten den mal, System Reboot, man kann ja auch in Switch, man kann ja auch
in Switch OS, ah cool, man kann ja auch direkt in Switch OS irgendwie switchen, wenn man
auf Router OS keinen Bock hat.
So, also Reboot, wo ist er, Reboot, yes, der Router Rebooted hier, ah guck mal da, oder
auch nicht.
Habt ihr gesehen, aber der Vierer hat Aktivität gehabt, ich glaub, der checkt's, der checkt's
grad einfach nicht mit Link Up und Link Down, der ist zu pepega dafür.
Hast du eigentlich schon vor deiner Ausbildung programmiert, ja, vielleicht gehen jetzt
die LEDs, also, was auch immer, warum die LEDs nicht da sind, ich hab keine Ahnung,
aber die Ports funktionieren, wir sehen ja hier oben, wenn der wieder on kommt, ist der
Switch gebootet, hoa, er hat was gemacht gerade, was ist eigentlich diese User LED, ist das
irgendwie CPU oder was, was ist das, okay, der ist wieder da, warum hat der keine LEDs,
muss man das irgendwie extra anschalten, Mikro Tic 800 305, wie ist das Ding nochmal,
genau, CAS RA5, LED, turns off all LED, was, LED is off, ich will LEDs on haben, System,
LEDs, okay, okay, okay, dann, wir gucken uns mal die LED-Config an, System, LED, LEDs,
guck mal, die haben, hier, Massive RGB-Champ, what the fuck is, what the fuck, ah, Moment,
braucht der ernsthaft, ne, der LED-Config, dass der, dass der Activity LEDs macht oder
was, jetzt wirklich, ah, hier, all LEDs off, ne, ne, never, never, never off, das kann
halt sein, ich wusste noch bei keinem Ding irgendwie LED-Config machen, sind die noch
dabei, das kann nicht sein, gibt es, gibt es auch das Gegenstück, all LED, ne, gibt
nur all LED off, aber das ist anscheinend so, guck mal, Power-LED und Ethernet-LED, also
die, die, die, die, die, die, die, Einport-Dings is off, okay, ich stelle da jetzt mal was
ein, Interface-Status, SFP plus, genau, eins, klar, und zeigt der jetzt was, ne, ist dem
vollkommen egal, achso, da ist die LED, ernsthaft jetzt, wirklich, gut, LED-Config, also, wer
musste nicht schon mal beim Switch die LED konfigurieren, alles klar, was kann man da
so schönes einstellen, alles, also bei der LED-Config meinst du jetzt, ne, aber ansonsten
die Switch, Router, alles mögliche einstellen, okay, also jetzt mal, jetzt mal zurück, zurück
zum links, also, 8,8, Quatsch, IP-Add, oh, ich kann mir das immer nicht merken, was, wie
hätte ich eine zweite, Second IP-Interface-Linux-IP-Add, ich kann mir das nicht merken, so, naja, mit
if, mit if-config krieg ichs noch hin, aber IP-Add ist the way to go, ja, ja, IP-Adr,
hier, genau das da, ne, ne, ne, das ganze, ganze Crap-Promo da net, okay, also, IP-Add,
8,8, Punkt 7, Slash, 24, Def, NS33, Operation not permitted, ist ja gut, okay, jetzt haben
wir eine IP auf dem Interface, alles klar, mal gucken, ob wir den anderen jetzt pingen
können, 6,8, nach 8,1 und bam, nein, Paint-Champ, Host Unreachable, oh, but why, ist die Frage,
verbunden ist er, verbunden ist er, Aktivitäts-LED hat er auch, da würd ich doch sagen, SwitchOS,
was ist die Default-IP-Switch, SwitchOS, 8,8,1, aber die Frage ist, auf welchem Interface,
vielleicht nicht auf jedem Interface, doch, bestimmt auf jedem Interface, tja, vielleicht
pingt das auch nicht, vielleicht gehen wir einfach mal da drauf, hopp, okay, dann würd
ich sagen, wir stöpseln mal den Raspberry Pi da direkt an, stöpseln den da oben an,
und zwar mit der normalen Netzwerkkarte, nicht mit diesem komischen Adapter da hier, gehst
du mal fort, normale Netzwerkkarte, ey, dieser Adapter, ich sag euch, der macht mich fertig,
ah, du kriegst dieses Kabel da teilweise nicht raus, es ist so beschissen gemacht, so, Seitenschneider-Champ
am Start, so, Raspberry Pi, ups, nicht runterfallen, bissi voll hier auf dem Tisch, aber okay, zack,
jetzt machen wir mal Port, Port 2 oder so, erst mal entknoten das ganze, Link, please,
Link ist ab, weiß nicht, ob ihr es seht, aber der Netzwerk Link blinkt, gut, gehen wir auf
den Raspberry Pi drauf und schauen wir mal, come on, Raspberry Pi, please, lass mich einloggen,
wo ist das Problem, sag bloß der Pi ist uns jetzt verreckt, ne, alter ist das lahm, okay,
um, wait a minute, achja, na klar, der Rest natürlich, der Raspberry Pi, aber die Verbindung
funktioniert zum Switch, sonst hätte der Raspberry Pi keine DRCP-IP gekriegt, der Raspberry Pi
hat eine DRCP-IP gekriegt und es kann nur sein, weil der Raspberry Pi da dran hängt,
dass zu dem Switch geht und der hängt per Uplink an meinem Ubiquiti-Switch drin, also
im Prinzip geht der Link, die Frage ist nur, warum komm ich per Switch, da ist er nicht
dran, IP, add, add, 8,8.5, slash, 24, device, eth0, bam, ah, jetzt geht's, von da, hä,
wait, warum geht das, das ergibt, das ergibt doch jetzt gar keinen Sinn, warum geht das
von dem Raspberry Pi und warum geht das nicht von meinem Desktop, die hängen, die hängen
quasi, ich meine, der eine muss noch zum anderen Switch drüber, aber die Verbindung funktioniert
ja, was, warum, ah, äh, nee, ich hätte gesagt, vielleicht liegt es an meiner Default-Rute,
dass er das automatisch rausschickt, aber das sollte der eigentlich kapieren, wie dem
auch sei, wir können jetzt Firefox aufmachen, per X-Forwarding, achso, äh,
Internet falsch, nee, nee, nee, alles richtig, alles richtig, Firefox, aber wie das geht,
weiß ich nicht, das muss über die SFP-Plus-Ports gehen, letztendlich hat er, hat ja der Raspberry
Pi auch eine IP gekriegt, so, wir machen das jetzt per X-Forwarding, ich mein, scheiß
drauf, ist zwar nicht schnell, aber, mein, es geht, nee, das ist, das ist vollkommen
egal, das ist, das ist, das ist ja, Switches miteinander verbunden, denen sind das mit
IPs, ist denen vollkommen egal, ok, 12216888.1, da sind wir, Mikrotik Switch OS, äh, Default-Name
Admin, ne, genau, so, das ist jetzt eher was für, für die meisten bei euch, glaub ich,
mit Switch OS ist die Sache ein bisschen easier, du hast nicht so viele 30 Milliarden Dinger,
du kannst die Sachen machen, die man so kennt von einem Switch, du kannst Ports benennen,
du kannst dir die Übersicht von den Ports angucken, du kannst Link Aggregation machen,
was das hier macht, weiß ich eigentlich, what the fuck, ich hab keine Ahnung, was das hier
tut, vielleicht kommst du mit SFP-Plus nicht auf die Config-IP, das können wir uns jetzt
ja gleich angucken, Link Aggregation, man kann Ports klonen wahrscheinlich, äh, das ist
eine Spanning-Tree-Geschichte, vermute ich mal, was auch immer, äh, Stats, Error, VLANs,
so, also die Config ist deutlich einfacher als Router OS, also die GUI ist vielleicht
nicht schön, aber man hat auf jeden Fall deutlich einfacher die ganzen Sachen als mit
Router OS, Router OS ist halt wirklich brain exploding, ja, so, wo kann ich mir denn jetzt
hier meine Management-IP angucken, Upgrade, das müsste eigentlich funktionieren, der Switch,
ok Moment, wie stellt man hier jetzt ein Management-IP und sowas, das hat SNMP, ja, das hat irgendwo
SNMP da, System, dhcp only, dhcp with fallback, das ist eigentlich top, dann rebooten wir
jetzt und dann sollte der eigentlich eine dhcp-IP bekommen, weil er kann jetzt, er kann ja jetzt
den Router erreichen, alternativ, ja komm, kann man ihm sagen, dass er neue dhcp ziehen
soll, ok, rebooten, wir rebooten einfach mal, er rebooted, exellent und ich guck nebenbei
in mein, in mein dhcp, ob das funktioniert, ob da sich was zieht, nur über Konsole-Firmware
upgraden, Moment, dhcp übelst unübersichtlich, ja gut, das macht er manchmal, so und jetzt
haben wir IP, hat das sich jetzt was gezogen, ja, 2 Punkt, ne, das ist der andere, 2 Punkt
136 ist der andere, 2 Punkt 137, 2 Punkt 137 haben wir noch, 2 Punkt 136 und 2 Punkt 137
oder auch nicht, meine Güte, die Firma scheint echt ein bisschen verbackt zu sein, was ist
das Problem jetzt, wo ist das Problem, so das ist der andere, das ist nicht der Switch,
das ist, das ist der kleine, also ich guck gerade in mein dhcp und da ist nichts und
da müsste sich ja eigentlich was ziehen, macht er aber nicht, kann der nicht IP, ne, ok,
da müssen wir auf Fallback warten, 88 Punkt 1, ok, da macht jetzt gar nichts mehr, jetzt
ist vorbei jetzt, jetzt juckt ihn gar nichts mehr, jetzt ist vorbei, jetzt juckt, jetzt
ist er kaputt, ne kaputt ist er, kaputt ist er nicht, aber kommt man da jetzt dran, also
weder, weder per IP ist er erreichbar noch per dhcp, das ist natürlich geil, Massive
Poggers, ok, vielleicht hat er einfach nicht richtig rebooted, vielleicht, vielleicht reboote
ich den nochmal von Hand, leuchtet, leuchtet, ja, activity leuchtet, ok, mal schauen, also
da, da ist er angeblich, der Raspberry Pi ist auch direkt dran, mich echt wundert, vielleicht
hat er doch ne dhcp gekriegt, aber ich hab es bei mir im Router jetzt übersehen, wenn
ich hier gucke, Mikrotik, 2 Punkt, ne, das ist der andere, Moment, ich mach jetzt mal
außen wieder an und dann gucken wir mal, zack, die Hardcore Variante, Kabel raus, Kabel rein,
ihr seht nix, ne, Kabel raus, Kabel rein, so und jetzt gucke ich mal in meinen dhcp, ob
da irgendwas auftaucht, iPad, das iPad taucht auf, super, das habe ich jetzt gebraucht,
mein, mein Raspberry Pi taugt auf, wunderbar, was ist denn das, 60, ach ne, das ist was
anderes, ich erinnere, wenn mein, what the fuck, aber wenn mein Pi auftaucht, bedeutet
das, dass der Switch funktioniert, ok, das ist mir zu big brain, das wird zu hoch Leute,
das muss ich mir glaube ich morgen allein in Ruhe mal angucken, bisschen rum basteln,
ne, also per dhcp kriegt er schon mal nix, per dhcp kommt nix, juckt hier nicht, wir können
nmae Podscan, exzellent, exzellent, ne, rc25 draufhauen ok, ja dazu müsste ich jetzt überhaupt
mal in irgendeiner Art und Weise dran kommen, ich komme ja gar nicht dran aktuell, ich komme
gar nicht dran, noch nicht mal px forwarding, gar nicht, der anfang, der pingt noch nimmer,
ne, meine IP ist weg, 0w, cacquade, da ist er wieder, ok, dhcp zieht sich schon mal gar
nicht, dhcp zieht sich schon mal gar nicht, das ist ok, also, da sind wir wieder, da sind
wir wieder, also, firmware, firmware updaten, exquisite firmware updaten, mikrotik, css610,
download, by the way chat, ich hab gesehen, dass ihr was gepostet habt, aber ich will
jetzt mal gucken, ob die das nicht offiziell auf ihrer Seite stehen haben, so, downloads,
haben wir da irgendwie, firmware gibt's, firmware gibt's gar nicht, haben wir uns gedacht, ne,
es ist so kaputt verlinken wir gar nicht, wir liefern den kaputt aus, haben aber keine
updates, exquisite, das müssen wir hier glaube ich aufmachen, ich muss mir jetzt aus denen
form ne beta firmware laden oder was, dass das ding überhaupt richtig funktioniert, geil,
ok 85€, ich hab nix gesagt, leute, led-config, ok, wo gibt's die firmware, ok, ok, ok, ok,
wo gibt's die firmware, rc25, ok, erstmal aus dubiosen quellen den kram runterladen,
alles klar, perfekt, genau das wollte ich schon immer haben, switchos, 2.13, rc25, top, ok,
wie macht man jetzt firmware update, upgrade, raus, ok, die firmware ist noch ganz schön
kaputt, leute, da sind wir, rc25, ja, da gab's ein paar verkackte rcs, wie's aussieht, upgrade,
es gibt noch keine richtige firmware version, anscheinend für das ding so neu ist das,
ilove, fuck, ne geprigged wird da nix, oh er ist weg, rib, rebootet er, macht er jetzt
Also wenn der Reboot geht natürlich der Raspberry Pi auch nicht, aber der Raspberry Pi geht
noch.
Was mich fraglich stimmt, ob das Firmware Update funktioniert.
Also für 85€ ist das ein richtig geiler Switch von den Features her.
Die brauchen wahrscheinlich noch 1-2 Monate bis die Firmware ordentlich funktioniert.
Also es ist quasi der No Man's Sky der Switche.
Ah jetzt hat er sich bei DHCP was gezogen Leute, die Firmware hat's gefixt, die Firmware
hat's gefixt, guck mal.
Da sind wir.
Jetzt können wir da auch drauf.
Ist das verbackt mit dem Online-Updaten, ist das verbackt irgendwie?
Kann man nicht übers Web-Interface upgraden, aber zumindest die Connection hat schon mal
getan.
Okay aber zumindest kommt mir jetzt schon mal ein paar Web-Interfaces auf den Switch
drauf.
Link ist ab, 1G, 10G, wunderbar.
Das ist aber von der Konfig ja schon mal einfach jetzt.
Jetzt machen wir noch mal was Leute, jetzt machen wir noch mal eine Sache, jetzt stöpseln
wir mal hier den Raspberry Pi dran mit dem 2,5G Adapter, dann probieren wir mal was aus.
Wir haben auch nicht mehr all zu viel Zeit.
Passt mal auf was wir jetzt machen.
Wir nehmen jetzt den 2,5G Adapter, den da, zack, und machen das Modul hier raus, machen
das Modul hier in den zweiten SFP-Plus-Port rein, falsch rum, und nun stöpseln wir die
2,5G mal dran und gucken mit was der es singt.
Weil die Firmware bei dem hier scheint ja recht ausgereift zu sein, mal gucken was er bei
dem macht.
Okay, Port ist ab, ja das buggt jetzt, jetzt muss ich das erst noch mal rausziehen glaube,
dann funktioniert es danach wieder.
Alles high quality, wie man sieht.
Aha, blinkt, Link, Link ist auch da.
Oh, okay es singt sich, alles gut, alles klar, gucken ob der jetzt hoch kommt mit 2,5, er
ist mit 2,5, okay das ist schon mal gut, dass das funktioniert, leckt das, hat es wieder
geleckt, das wäre ein Witz, das wäre geil, okay der singt mit 2,5, oh, sag mal geht der
ab und down, kann das sein, oh, what the fuck, das ist jetzt aber die verbackte, das ist
die verbackte Netzwerkkarte, äh, das ist die verbackte Netzwerkkarte, ich hab immer
noch nicht geschafft den offiziellen Treiber zu inszenieren, ich hab extra auf den Pi
Ubuntu 20.10 gemacht und das ist immer noch verbackt, der USB Netzwerkkartentreiber.
Okay, machen wir mal einen Speedtest, ich hoffe der geht jetzt über den richtigen Adapter,
IPperf und jetzt, also erst mal installieren, ich mein mit dem Raspberry 3 da jetzt einen
2,5G Test zu machen ist natürlich fail, aber was willst du machen, ich hab grad nix anderes
am Start und ähm, ja, gucken wir mal ob der überhaupt über die richtige Netzwerkkarte
geht, ne der geht über Gigabit, der geht über Gigabit, ne, ne, ne, ne, der Pi kann
er mit 2,5, ne, ne, nicht wirklich, nicht, nicht wirklich, das ist eher so einfach gucken
ob die Verbindung geht und das wars, ne, nicht wirklich, ähm, ich muss glaube ich die, muss
mich darüber connecten auf den Pi, weil der sonst das nicht checkt über welchen Anschluss
er das machen soll, aber die machen wir mal ab, jetzt muss der Pi erst mal checken, dass
er wieder an ist, ah ne hat er schon, okay nice, wobei ich kann auch einfach über W-Lan,
ah ich blick grad einmal durch SSH Ubuntu Add, jaja, SSH Key, ne, was wars noch mal,
minus R, äh, war nicht SSH Keygen, es war, ob man das noch mal entfernen, ich mein ich
kann es aus der Textart teilen, was SSH Keygen minus R, wirklich, tatsächlich, ha, ich hätt
dazu was anderes, so, also, sind wir am Start, also Listening, IPerf, okay jetzt geht er,
jetzt geht er über die, ähm, über die 2,5G, 2,5G, aber das geht, das funktioniert halt
nicht, ne, also sprich, kannst du knicken, der ist zwar gesunken mit 2,5G, aber das schafft
der Raspberry Pi nicht mehr, und übrigens Reverse spackt die, ah geht doch, guck mal
Leute, wir haben einen Ticken mehr, einen Ticken mehr als 1G, also man sieht, dass es
prinzipiell funktioniert, aber der spackt schon mit Retry übelst rum, was hältst du
von Webmin, gar nichts, also es ist auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall hat er schon mal mit
2,5G gesyncht, und es funktioniert auch, das wäre, das würde wahrscheinlich noch
deutlich besser funktionieren, wäre diese kack Netzwerkkarte nicht so verbackt, guckt
euch das mal an, jaja mit dem, ich hab's nicht geschafft den 3er installiert zu bekommen,
ich hab's doch noch mal auf Ubuntu probiert, es funktioniert, vielleicht ist es ein Abendproblem,
ja nice, funktioniert auch prinzipiell alles, sehr schön, so und auf Switch OS kann man
wie gesagt bei weitem nicht so viel machen wie mit Router OS, aber es ist halt ein bisschen
einfacher, man kann übrigens auch sagen mit Wasser, ok das ist ziemlich beknackt, warum
soll ich den auf 1G stellen, ne ne Auto, wenn ich nix anderes einstellen kann, ist ja total
hängen geblieben, die LEDs, ne die LEDs gehen, die LEDs bei dem funktionieren, man sieht
es nicht richtig gut, aber guckt die LEDs bei dem gehen, nur die LEDs bei dem anderen,
bei dem da, bei dem da spacken bisschen rum, ok nice nice nice, Errors, Stats, VLANs, zeig
mal her, VLANs, wie macht man eine VLAN-Config mit Switch OS, VLANs, Sword das sind alle
VLANs, oder was, Default VLAN 1, alles ok, only tagged, untagged, ok only untagged, könnte
man machen, wenn man will, dass der Switch das, also wenn man da kein Trunkport machen
will, dann kann man auch sagen, ok wir wollen rein, darf nur untagged traffic, alternativ
könnte man auch sagen, das kriegt nen Default VLAN und es nimmt auch tagged traffic, aber
wie sagt man eben jetzt, dass er nen VLAN anlegt, so wir sind dran über Port SFP 2 sind
wir dran ne, wir sind dran über SFP, SFP 2, ok, das Mods, Mods Tricked, VLANs, wie addet
man jetzt hier was, wo ist hier denn ein adden Knopf, ach append oder was, alter append,
jetzt ernsthaft hätte man es nicht adden nennen können, append, das ist ja die ppp
gleichste Bezeichnung, die ich da für je gesehen hab, ok, VLAN ID 420, members, was,
was ist das für n scheiß GUI, sind das hier die Ports oder was, hat das, hat das der Praktikant
mit jQuery gemacht oder was, apply, excellent, ok Tricked packt er mich immer da rein, das
bringt mir jetzt ja nix, da bräuchte ja ein zweites Gerät, wo ich das noch, wo ich das
noch mit rein packe, was ich jetzt nicht hab, aber ok, ok aber da komm ich, da komm ich
dahinter, also auf jeden Fall nice, was kann man bei ACLs machen, append, append kann
man schonmal, ah das ist so Port Security Lite oder was ist das, account, alter was
ist das für n GUI, nee das ist nicht mal Port Security Lite, ich hab ehrlich gesagt
keine Ahnung was es ist, na doch, ich kann sagen es muss, muss, muss die MAC Adresse
dahinter sein, ok, dass das funktioniert, boah aber das GUI ist nun wirklich schon echt
Pains Champ, richtiges Pains Champ, ob der das auch kann, kein Schimmer, ACL, like yeah,
append, nee ich glaub du kannst die, account S, what the fuck, mirror 2, ok man kann den
Spiegel, redirect support, ok, nee man kann anscheinend bloß Sachen plocken, man kann
anscheinend bloß Sachen plocken, also wenn dahinter ein Gerät ist mit falscher MAC dann
ist vorbei, nee, nee das war nicht viel, kannst du da wahrscheinlich nicht, aber mal
ganz im Ernst, für einfache Sachen ist das ja vollkommen ausreichend, aber ist schon
ein bisschen weird, ne, zumindest ist es schon mal gut, dass man das mal sehen kann, dann
nennen wir das mal irgendwie hier, Uplink, SFP1, da wissen wir schonmal, da wissen wir
schonmal was Sache ist, und das wird mal, also das wird Uplink, SFP1 und das hier wird,
das hier wird, desktop SFP1, letztendlich, also so werde ich das ganze aufteilen, die
Firmware ist crap, aber für 85 Euro ist wirklich nice, da kann man sie nicht beschweren, also
von der Idee her will ich das so machen, das gibt den Uplink zu meinen Ubiquiti 10G Switch
im Serverraum hinten, hier kommt mein Desktop dran und die können eigentlich so bleiben,
alles andere, ich werde da auch WLAN mäßig wahrscheinlich nix großartig machen erstmal,
was aber cool ist, ich könnte mir zum ersten mal beispielsweise das WLAN, wo die ganzen
Access Points drin sind, an Desktop holen damit in irgendeiner Art und Weise, die sind
glaube ich auf Hochtourn gerade am Programmieren was Firmware angeht, werde ich dann morgen
mal anschließen, so Leute, ich hoffe, oder frage ich mal, hat euch der Stream gefallen?
So, was ist das, das ist ein 3D gedruckter Keks, exzellent, den stellen wir jetzt hier
hin, so, ja, der ist, das ist nicht ganz original Keks, man sieht es ja hier, da fehlt ja was
hier, ne, da fehlt was, ein original Keks, ja, so, nice Leute, ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen,
RolloWee, Dankeschön für den Prime Sub, wir gucken jetzt morgen in den Chat rein, fällt
mir gerade ein, habe ich noch gar nicht gemacht, was habe ich denn hier vergessen, Chat, Cute
Chat, wo sind wir?
Das kann ich mir heute alles angucken, ok, also fangen wir von unten nach oben an, ja,
der ist nice, der ist nice, den habe ich, ne, ich habe den Hex PoE, ich habe nicht den
Hex S, ich habe den Hex PoE, echt, schafft er, schafft er kein Gigabit komplett, also
der Hex PoE kriegt das ziemlich sicher hin, hast du da irgendwie viel Fireball regeln
oder so drinne, weil ansonsten, zeig mal, ah, das ist die, die ist alt, ich glaube,
das ist der, der hat irgendwie auch nur ne, ne, das muss der packen, das muss der packen,
das muss der, guck mal, der sollte, der sollte überhaupt keine Probleme haben, dein Wunder
von solch zu routen, aber absolut gar nicht, der kriegt ja fast zwei, der kriegt ja fast
2G da drüber, also, das wäre, das, machst du damit irgendwie was besonderes, weil der
sollte, der sollte einen Standard Gigabit Wunder von eigentlich easy geroutet bekommen.
So, die Musik leiser, äh, zu spät, aber ich glaube, die war echt, teilweise ein bisschen
laut, so, weil der Raspberry definitiv maximal synkt mit 1G und der Adapter synkt mit 2,5G,
das heißt, ich kann testen, ob die 10G Ports auch mit 2,5G gehen, übertakken, was sonst,
und RGB natürlich, jaja, 88 ist das Nazi Netz, genau, was machen denn alle, die 88
geboren sind, ja, deswegen, deswegen setzt sich ja auch im Konsumerbereich, so mit der
Zeit, jetzt 2,5 und 5G durch, weil das alles easy auch über ältere, äh, Kopferkabel
mit R45 Stecker geht, preislich ist 10G daheim auch überhaupt kein Problem, doch 10 Rules
sollte da auch packen, es sei dann, dass es irgendwie was super kompliziert ist, guck
doch mal, ob der CPU mäßig am Limit ist in den Stats, heissklebe-Champ, nope, hat er,
wie gesagt, von Webman halte ich gar nichts, brauchen wir nicht, alles per SSH und gut
ist, ok, war ja nichts, also Leute, machts gut, leiser Unboxing Stream, wir sehen uns
beim nächsten Mal, bis dann, see you!